Die Ligatour ist mal wieder da. Wir wollen blicken auf den europäischen Fußball der Männer. Heute sind drei Ligen dran. Spanien, Italien und in einem einzelnen Segment noch England. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Schön, dass Fabian Pakulat und Christian Bernhardt hier sind. Und später hören wir noch Uli Hebel. Und genau jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und schön, dass ich hier wieder bekannte Gesichter habe. Hallo Fabian.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Du schleppst dich hier in die Aufzeichnung. Vielen, vielen Dank. Ich hoffe, du hältst durch. Und durchhalten wird hoffentlich auch Christian Bernhard, der hier neben mir sitzt. Hallo Christian. Hallo Max. Wunderschönen guten Morgen. Ihr seid heute wunderbar luftig angezogen. Ist euch das eigentlich aufgefallen, dass ich hier quasi so das schwarze oder blaue Schaf bin? Der Frühling kommt näher. Oder ist es schon da? Also, naja, gut, hier in München würde ich, also haben wir immer einen Tag Frühling und dann wird es wieder, dann wird es wieder matschig. Ich nehme an, Fabian, bei dir ist es besser. Aber bevor wir jetzt über das Wetter reden, dann machen wir zu viele Ligatouren. Wenn wir irgendwann anfangen, über das Wetter zu reden, dann glaube ich, müssen wir die Sendefrequenz zurückfahren. Wollen wir einsteigen in die Ligen? Also wir beginnen jetzt mit Spanien und Italien, später hören wir noch England und dann haben wir eine etwas kompaktere Ligatur, wobei immer wenn ich das sage, kommen zwei Stunden Sendung bei raus. Ich bin mal gespannt. Fabian, bei euch war einiges los in Spanien, da gab es Hausdurchsuchungen und der DFB kann sich freuen, er ist nicht der einzige Verband, der eine Razzia über sich ergehen lassen muss, sondern das ist dem Spanischen Fußballverband jetzt auch passiert. Was ist da los?
Ja, leider mal wieder. In Spanien ist die Produktion mal wieder richtig zugangen, nicht nur im Fußball, auch in der Politik geht es wieder hoch und runter. Es wird aus diesem Land nicht wirklich rausgehen, diese Machenschaften und es geht, wem wundert es, unter anderem um ehemaligen spanischen Fußballpräsident Luis Rubiales, den viele vielleicht noch kennen aus dem Sommer, aus der WM-Geschichte der spanischen Damen und dem verbotenen Kuss sozusagen. Im Endeffekt ist noch nicht so viel herausgedrungen. Die Untersuchungen haben erst gestern Mittwoch stattgefunden bzw. sie haben begonnen. Sie sind unter anderem in die Zentrale, also in die Bürogebäude des spanischen Verbandes ein, also eine Sondereinheit der Polizei ist dort eingestiegen, unter anderem aber auch bei Rubiales selbst in seiner Wohnung in Granada im Zentrum und haben dort Dokumente beschlagnahmt. Und im Großen und Ganzen wird es wohl um die Geschichte des Supercups gehen, der ja seit 2020 in Saudi-Arabien ausgetragen wird und wo der spanische Verband angeblich pro Austragung 40 Millionen Euro dafür bekommt.
Pro einmalige Austragung?
Also einmalige Austragung pro Jahr 40 Millionen Euro und das, glaube ich, für zehn Jahre hat das verkauft. Und es gab ja schon damals, als es losging, Veröffentlichungen von WhatsApp-Aufnahmen zwischen Rubiales und Piquet damals, wo schon so ein bisschen abgesprochen wurde, wer wie viel Geld bekommt und dort wurde ja auch schon mehr oder weniger klar, dass Rubiales und auch Piquet selbst sich da mit ein bisschen bereichert haben bei der Geschichte und ich denke, jetzt wird es dann endlich dazu kommen, dass sie der Sache auf den Grund gehen. Warum das so lange gedauert hat, weiß ich nicht. Das ist damals alles ein bisschen im Sand verfroren. Vielleicht konnten sie damals auch nichts belegen, aber jetzt suchen sie nochmal. Und ja, die kuriose Geschichte ist jetzt, es gibt jetzt einen Haftbefehl für Rubiales, der allerdings gerade nicht in Spanien ist, sondern in der Dominikanischen Republik. Dort ist anscheinend öfter nicht zum Urlaub machen, sondern angeblich, weil er dort auch viele Geschäfte ablaufen hat. Und die letzte News, die ich habe, ist, dass er wohl das Land auch dort verlassen hat, weil Spanien und die Dominikanische Republik ein Ausführungsabkommen haben oder ein Auslieferungsabkommen haben, wenn es Haftbefehle gibt. Und das hat er wohl relativ zeitnah erfahren und ist leider nicht in ein anderes Land getingelt. Und das ist im Moment so der Stand der Dinge. Viele Dokumente werden jetzt durchsucht und durchleuchtet, aber es sollte uns alle nicht überraschen, wenn sich da einige selbst bereichert haben.
Ja, und selbst bereichert haben. Ich meine, Rubiales sagt, PK hat das ja quasi im Namen einer Vermittlungsagentur gemacht. Und Rubiales sagt, diese Agentur wurde allein von Saudi-Arabien bezahlt. Es sei nie Geld vom Spanischen Verband an diese Agentur geflossen. Ob das schon reicht, um diesen Verdacht auszuräumen, ich weiß es persönlich nicht. Was ja damals rauskam bei diesen Chat-Nachrichten, war ja unter anderem, dass Real und Barca jeweils 8 Millionen Euro fürs Antreten bekommen. Und andere spanische Vertreter – es wird ja mit vier Teams, glaube ich, inzwischen ausgespielt – bekommen nur 2 Millionen Euro. Wurde das denn noch mal aufgearbeitet oder ist das jetzt einfach so stehen geblieben und…
Das wurde hingenommen. Es ist doch im Endeffekt auch ganz klar, da machen sich die Spanier auch nichts vor. Und wenn man sich Spiele anschaut im Supercup in Saudi-Arabien, dann waren halt die Spiele von Real und Barca gut besucht oder ausverkauft. Und die anderen Partien nicht. Christian, auch beim Supercup in Italien hast du es ja auch gesehen, wenn dort keine namenhaften Teams dabei sind, dann geht da halt auch keiner hin. Und dementsprechend ist man sich in Spanien dort schon klar, dass die Großen mehr verdient haben. Dass es ungerechte Verteilungen gibt in Spanien, das wird inzwischen so hingenommen. Das ist einfach so. Und ja, damit lebt man hier und gesteht es auch diesen großen Teams ein, weil ja im Endeffekt jeder, egal wo er wohnt, auch trotzdem noch Barca oder Realfan ist. Zumindest der Großteil der Bevölkerung. Und dementsprechend wird dem wirklich sehr, sehr viel zugestanden, auf politischer Ebene, auf finanzieller Ebene. Aber das ist ja ein Thema für einen eigenen Podcast. Aber ich habe dir ja vorher schon gesagt, Max, ich habe zu jedem meinem Thema heute einen direkten Zug zum FC Malaga. Einer dieser Menschen aus dem Spanischen Fußballverband, der jetzt auch ins Zwillig geraten ist und der da mitgemacht haben soll bei der Geldwäsche und bei der Selbstbereicherung heißt Pedro González und war unter Altani beim FC Malaga auch hier finanzieller Mitarbeiter. Er war zwar nicht Geschäftsführer, aber er hat auch hier ein bisschen mitgemauschelt.
Das gibt einem doch ein gutes Gefühl. Aber würdet ihr denn sagen, jetzt haben wir ja diese Super Cup-Auftragung in Saudi-Arabien jetzt ja schon länger gesehen. Also einmal hat es noch in Spanien stattgefunden wegen Corona, aber ansonsten seit 2019, glaube ich, ist der Super Cup dort. Und bei Italien bin ich mir jetzt gerade nicht sicher. In Italien hat nachgezogen, also es war jetzt in dem Format, im Vierer-Format war es dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal. Und auch ganz kurz zu Fabian, weil er es sehr angerissen hat. Auch da, man muss sich mal die finanziellen Dimensionen klarmachen. Fabian hat ja die Zahl aus Spanien genannt. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht mehr hundertprozentig sicher bei der Italienischen. Ich hatte es damals beim Kommentieren parat. Aber ich glaube, sie haben durch das Verschieben nach Saudi-Arabien des Super Cups die Liga das vervierfacht auch. Also das, was sie sozusagen an Geld einnehmen, was sie dann teilweise auch an die Vereine ausschütten können. Aber logischerweise, was auch an ihnen hängen bleibt. Also nur, um mal zu verdeutlichen, über was für finanzielle Dimensionen wir da eben sprechen. Ja klar, wenn die spanische Liga 40 Millionen Euro pro Austragung bekommt, dann ist das fast ein Fünftel dessen, was die Bundesliga insgesamt im Ausland an TV-Rechten erlöst. Also es sind natürlich unterschiedliche Dinge und so weiter und so fort. Aber die Dimensionen, die sind da schon groß. Aber gab es einen großen Aufschrei? Hier scheint das ja eine der berühmten roten Linien zu sein, die nicht überschritten werden darf. Donato Hopfen ist mutmaßlich unter anderem über dieses Zitat gestolpert, dass sie gesagt hat, naja, das ist durchaus mal vorstellbar, dass man Supercup-Finale woanders austrägt. War das in Italien ein großes Thema? Das war logisch, in den Kurven war es ein großes Thema. Ist ja klar, da hat sich jetzt niemand… Die hätten gerne logisch Inter in San Siro gesehen oder Inter im Olympico. Und das Schöne ist ja auch, ich weiß nicht, wie es in Spanien ist, aber in Italien war wirklich in den Jahren davor, diese Supercup-Finale, die waren wirklich von der Stimmung her sehr besonders, weil einfach so ähnlich wie beim Pokalfinal ist das 50-50 des Stadions sozusagen und das war dann halt für die Fans wirklich auch ja was Besonderes. Und dann war ja klar, okay, wir spielen das in Saudi-Arabien und alle haben gesagt, okay, alles klar, sagt halt gleich, es geht nur ums Geld und euch liegt halt 0, 0 an uns. Kleiner Einklammern, was wunderbar reinpasst, im Zuge als die Liga, als die Serie A dann den Supercup ausgetragen hat, als alle honorigen Personen logischerweise auch in Saudi-Arabien war, da fiel der Satz vom Liga-Boss, man denke ja darüber nach, in Zukunft vielleicht auch mal einen kompletten Spieltag der Liga, einen kompletten im Ausland durchzuführen. Viel Spaß bei Fosinone gegen Salernitana. Abgesehen davon aber allein der Gedanke, das hat logisch auch für großes Aufsehen, ja und die Fans sollen die dann nach Ecuador fliegen oder so, um dann Fosinone gegen Salernitana anzuschauen. Aber nur um zu verdeutlichen, ich glaube, da bewegen sich halt, das sind halt zwei Planeten, die halt in keinster Weise miteinander Berührungspunkte haben, weil es sollte bei Planeten auch nicht so sein, aber… Guter Punkt, danke Max für dein Astronomisch.
Da wurde lange diskutiert, ob sie ein Ligaspiel in der USA austragen.
Eins, genau, aber in Italien war jetzt die Runde, ob man nicht mal den kompletten Spieltag sogar ins Ausland wächst. Genau, und also nur um zu verdeutlichen, das hat logischerweise 0, 0 mit der Basis zu tun, aber da sieht man halt, da werden zwei unterschiedliche Spiele gespielt.
Und ich gebe da Christian Recht, der Supercup hatte auch hier einen schönen Status. Er war damals ja nur vor der Saison und jetzt nicht irgendwie so mittendrin. Und dann war das halt der Saisonabtag, da war halt einfach die Freude da, die Leute hatten wieder Bock auf Fußball und haben ihre besten Teams gesehen und haben schon mal gesehen, wo stehen die im Moment. Und da war, wie Christian schon sagt, eigentlich die Hälfte des Stadion von einem Team, die Hälfte von einem anderen, das war immer ein Fußballfest und für die Fans ist es natürlich eine Katastrophe. Und es ist sogar so, dass du in Spanien, wenn du den Super Cup in Saudi-Arabien sehen willst, obwohl du schon dieses Pay-TV hast, wo eigentlich die Gegner dabei ist, ich glaube, das musst du da nochmal extra drauf tun.
Ach, come on.
Also natürlich wird da wieder extra abgecashed. Also das ist absolut…
Das ist ja lustig, weil dann sagt du mir quasi, in Spanien und Italien hat dieser Super Cup auch für die Fans einen Wert. Das ist ja komplett anders in Deutschland. Die organisierten Fans zählen, boykottieren den schon seit Jahren. Deswegen ist die Stimmung vor Ort auch immer anders. Und letztlich durch die Verlegung nach Saudi-Arabien haben wir jetzt wahrscheinlich dann eine ähnliche Stimmung. Und in Deutschland, wo es eigentlich dann wahrscheinlich noch weniger Aufschrei gäbe, weil die organisierten Fans zählen, die sagen, pff, wir sind eh noch nie zu diesem Spiel gekommen. Naja, so ist das halt. Ach, der schöne deutsche Fußball und europäische Fußball. Wir schauen mal, was rauskommt bei diesen Untersuchungen. Das war unser erstes Thema. Dann würde ich sagen, schauen wir mal in die Serie A. Und vielleicht beginnen wir da auch mit dem unangenehmen Thema. Allerdings, genau. Gehen wir auch mal weg vom Spielfeld. Ja, gut, nee, wir gehen nicht weg vom Spielfeld. Es ist auf dem Spielfeld passiert. Also, vergangenes Wochenende, Sonntag, Inter gegen Napoli, Abschluss des Spieltags, ja, großer Kracher. 1 zu 1, das sportliche Ergebnis. Aber seit Tagen wird nicht über das Sportliche gesprochen, sondern über einen angeblichen Rassismus-Vorfall, und zwar auf dem Feld, unter Spielern. Ich schildere das mal kurz, was passiert sein soll. Francesco Acerbi, Inter-Verteidiger, Nationalmannschaft, italienischer Nationalspieler, soll Juan Jesus, Napoli-Verteidiger, mit dem N-Wort auf dem Feld sozusagen beleidigt haben. Also, ich habe das Spiel kommentiert. Man hat leider während dem Spiel, man hat das aus dem Spiel heraus nicht verstehen können. Also, es gab spät in der zweiten Hälfte, ist Juan Jesus zum Schiedsrichter, hat auf ihn eingeredet, aber man konnte damals aufgrund der Bilder leider nicht nahelegen. Also, ich dachte am Anfang, da geht es um eine strittige Situation. Was aber war, Juan Jesus ist zum Schiedsrichterin, hat ihm gesagt, hey, pass mal auf, er hat das N-Wort bei mir benutzt. Der Schiedsrichter muss wohl, hat dann Acerbi auch zu sich geholt. Acerbi soll sich da entschuldigt haben. Und der Schiedsrichter hat wohl auch Juan Jesus gefragt, ob er das Spiel abbrechen soll. Weil es gibt ja die Regel her. Juan Jesus soll das verneint haben, er meinte, nein, ich möchte, dass wir weiterspielen. Und Juan Jesus hat auch direkt im Anschluss ans Spiel gemeint, für ihn ist die Sache erledigt, es sind Sachen, die auf dem Feld passieren können. Er hat die Entschuldigung von Acerbi sozusagen angenommen und für ihn sei das Thema dadurch durch. Es war Sonntagabend, wie gesagt. Am Montag trifft sich die italienische Nationalmannschaft zu den Länderspielen. Acerbi ist auch da, reist an, reist aber sofort wieder ab, weil der italienische Verband eine Pressemitteilung rausgibt und sagt, aufgrund der noch ungeklärten Situation sehen wir es besser, wenn wir Spieler aus der Schusslinie nehmen. Acerbi fährt mit dem Zug zurück und gibt in Mailand aussteigend ein Statement ab vor Journalisten – da waren sehr viele – und sagt, er habe nie eine rassistische Formulierung benutzt. Womöglich habe Juan Jesús ihn missverstanden. Er ist komplett gegen Rassismus, er ist seit 20 Jahren Profi, er weiß, was er sagt. Wie gesagt, er hat nichts in der Art gesagt. Und daraufhin hat Juan Jesús am Montag auch noch einen langen Instagram-Post abgegeben und gemeint, na, jetzt muss er sich nochmal melden. Für ihn wäre das eigentlich durch gewesen. Aber so wie er Cerves darstellt, stimmt es halt überhaupt nicht. Er nochmal bekräftigt, dass das N-Wort gefallen sei. Und jetzt haben wir den Fakt, dass wir heute Donnerstag richtig sind, also die italienische Sportgerichtsbarkeit ermittelt. Es soll auch diese Woche noch beide Spieler angehört werden, der Schiedsrichter auch. Das ist ja auch die Frage, was hat der Schiedsrichter in seinen Bericht reingeschrieben. Da steht wohl dieser Vorwurf drin auch sozusagen. Ich glaube, am Freitag soll es zur Anhörung kommen. Im Raum steht, wenn Acerbi verurteilt werden sollte, wären es mindestens zehn Spieltagesperre. Das gibt der Kodex in Italien her, wenn es um rassistische Beleidungen oder auch homophobe Beleidungen unter Spielern gibt. Die EM-Teilnahme ist definitiv in Gefahr. Spalletti ist einer, der auf solche Werte großen Wert legt. Ich gehe davon aus, dass Acerbi nicht bei der EM dabei sein wird. Da wäre er dabei gewesen, keine Frage. Jetzt ist die große Frage, wie du das beweist. Es gibt logischerweise Kameraperspektiven, es werden jetzt auch schon Lippenleser. Diese Nummer ist im Gang. Die Verteidigungsstrategie von Acerbi beruhe wohl darauf, dass er – es gibt ein italienisches Sprichwort, das heißt, die faccionero, übersetzt gesagt, ich mache dich schwarz. Das steht dafür, dass die Augen schwarz werden, also ich haue dir ein paar rein. Das wäre übersetzt. Zwischen Nero und dem italienischen N-Wort ist nur ein Buchstabenunterschied. Angeblich beruht seine Strategie darauf, dass er ihm angeblich so etwas gesagt haben soll. Dagegen steht die Aussage von Jesus total. Das ist nur die Faktenlage, aber logischerweise können wir gerne darüber reden, es ist ein größerer Rahmen, der sich darüber zieht. So viel zu den Fakten. Aber wie empfindest du den Umgang damit? Wir hatten jetzt schon manchmal Rassismusvorfälle. Wenn du jetzt z.B. sagst, es gibt da drastische Strafen, das scheint mir erst mal etwas Gutes zu sein. Unabhängig von diesem Fall, dass es da quasi einen Strafenkatalog gibt. Ich finde auch, im ersten Moment dachte ich, okay, 10 Spieltage Sperre ist definitiv eine Ansage. Plus, da würde auch ein Markt an ihm hängen bleiben, was der Cherb ist, glaube ich 36. Sein Vertrag bei Inter läuft noch ein Jahr. Es ist auch zu vernehmen, dass man bei Inter logischerweise alles andere als glücklich über die ganze Sache ist. Auch wie der Cherb sich eben in den Tagen verhalten hat, auch sein Berater, der hat sich auch gleich hingestellt und gesagt, ne ne ne, da ist überhaupt nichts gewesen und so. Also, was das für Cherbi noch alles für personelle Konsequenzen hat, sei dahingestellt. Ich war auch, ja, 10 Spieltage ist viel. Jetzt haben wir nur, wir hatten ja gerade erst vor kurzem den Fall mit Menyar, der beim Udinese-Auswärtsspiel von Fans rassistisch beleidigt wurde. Die konnten ausfindig gemacht wurden, auch durch Polizeikameras. Und die Polizei hat den, es waren jetzt vier Menschen, ich glaube drei Männer und eine Frau. Und die haben ein Stadionverbot für fünf Jahre bekommen. So, jetzt kann man logischerweise die Frage stellen, ein Fan, also nochmal, bei Cherbi ist es noch nicht bewiesen. Aber ich sage, die Frage ist, genau, ein Fan wird für fünf Jahre, sage ich mal, aus dem Verkehr gezogen. Ein Spieler bekäme, unter Anführungszeichen, nur zehn Spieltagesperre. Die Frage kann man hinstellen, was logisch unfassbar, also der Vorfall an sich ist ja schlimm genug, egal wann er passiert. An dem Spieltag stand der Italien-Serie-Spieltag auch noch unter dem Zeichen Kampf gegen den Rassismus. Juan Jesus sieht man, wie er zum Schiedsrichter geht, auch auf den Patch zeigt. Heute Kampf gegen den Rassismus. Das ist logisch maximal unglücklich und damit schließt sich jetzt halt der Kreis zum wie der italienische Fußball mit Rassismus-Vorfällen umgeht. Und da muss man jetzt sagen, wie gesagt, das Ganze ist am Sonntagabend passiert. Es hat schon, auf Social Media ging es schon eigentlich direkt mit Spielschluss los, dass das klar war oder war was. Es wurden auch schon Spieler in den Interviews danach dazu befragt. Die haben dann logisch von den meisten gekommen, wir haben nichts mitbekommen, wissen wir nicht. Aber allein, wie die Verantwortlichen damit umgegangen sind. Inter hat zum Beispiel erst 16 Stunden nach dem Spiel ein kurzes Statement, wo auch keine Entschuldigung Richtung Juan Jesus drin war, sondern mehr so, wir behalten uns erstmal vor, anzuhören, was Acerbi dazu sagt, wo man die Frage stellen kann, wenn ihr 16 Stunden danach noch nicht von eurem Spieler wisst oder euch habt sagen lassen, was seiner Meinung nach passiert ist, kann man die Frage mal stellen. Der einzige italienische Serie A-Verein, der am Tag danach sozusagen einen Tweet abgegeben hat, so von wegen, wir stehen an der Seite von Juan Jesus, war Milan, von kein anderem Ding. Und das sind wir jetzt halt beim strukturellen Problem, das in Italien ist, immer wenn solche Fälle auftreten, die Verantwortlichen, du hast direkt das Gefühl, dass die Kartoffel so heiß ist, dass eigentlich niemand sich traut, irgendwie Position dazu zu beziehen. Also erstmal ist es so bei den meisten, oh, jetzt warten wir mal ab, was kommt raus bei den Ermittlungen. Und das zeigt halt so dieses Strukturelle, dass das halt in Italien immer noch ein riesen Problem ist, wie mit diesem schwerwiegen Thema umgegangen wird. Und letzte Frage, glaube ich dazu, weil man könnte da jetzt ewig… Ja, das ist auch eine eigene Sendung, wie Fabian sagte. Aber glaubst du, da gehört noch der größere politische Kontext mit dabei, dass man mit jetzt Meloni eine rechtsausgerichtete, schrägstrich, faschistische Regierungspräsidentin hat, zumindest in manchen Ansichten? Wenn ich mir so die Geschichte der letzten Jahre anschaue, habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass es sich verändert hat. Es gab immer wieder mal solche Fälle, vielleicht erinnern sich ein paar. Es gab vor ein paar Jahren, ich weiß nicht wie viele, da war Mois Ken, der Juve-Stürmer. In Caliari war das, der aus der Caliari Kurve mit Affenlauten bedacht wurde. Der hat das nach dem Spiel direkt öffentlich gemacht. Und dann war Leonardo Bonucci, damals noch bei Juve. Ken war damals noch ziemlich jung, der das so ein bisschen eingefangen hat im Sinn von, ja Mois, du musst halt auch ein bisschen aufpassen, wie du dich sozusagen auf dem Feld... Also weißt du, was ich damit sagen will? Also es zeigt eben, es ist ein Thema in Italien, also im Fußball und logisch auch in der Gesellschaft. Ich weiß nicht, wo es richtig problematisch ist, das Ganze zu fassen. Deswegen nochmal darauf zurückzukommen. Ich hatte das Gefühl, es war vor Meloni auch schon. Also ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass das jetzt irgendwie nochmal mehr wurde oder eine größere Öffentlichkeit oder häufiger auftritt. Ich habe mir extra nochmal Zahlen jetzt rausgesucht. Es gibt ja so offizielle staatliche Stellen, die Rassismus-Vorfälle zahlenmäßig auch aufnehmen. Da gibt es auch eine Sparte, die das im Fußball machen sozusagen. Und da ist anscheinend in den letzten 3, 4 Jahren war es immer leicht ansteigend. Also auch schon vor Meloni sozusagen. Also es ist ein riesen strukturelles Problem. Und das ist jetzt halt ein Fall, wo Spieler beteiligt sind, auch noch ein Nationalspieler. Und ein Satz noch zu Acerbi. Acerbi hat von relativ vielen Zuspruch bekommen, weil er – ich weiß nicht, vielleicht erinnere ich mich auch noch – Acerbi hat eine besondere Lebensgeschichte. Er hat einen Krebs besiegt. Und er hat auch öffentlich darüber gesprochen und hat dadurch sehr, sehr viele, ja, sehr positives Feedback bekommen. Weil es ein Mann ist, der ja, sagen wir mal, außerhalb des Fußballfälles eigentlich auch schon Sachen mitgemacht hat, die ja existenziell sozusagen sind. Und dann kam jetzt von ein paar Seiten, na, wir können uns nicht vorstellen, dass einer wie Acerbi… Und das sind halt immer die Sachen. Genau, Max, deine Reaktion ist, das ist ja allein, falls das Wort gefallen sein sollte, wenn das Teil seines Vokabulars ist, dann sind wir da ja schon beim strukturellen Problem und dementsprechend… Vor allem in der Regel sind das immer weiße Menschen oder nicht zu einer Minderheit gehörende Menschen, die sagen, ich kann mir das eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen. Und wenn du Betroffenen zuhörst, die können sich das immer vorstellen, weil die es schon hundertfach erlebt haben. Also wie gesagt, schauen wir mal, ich glaube, die italienische Sportgerichtsbarkeit hat ein großes Interesse, das jetzt auch schnell durchzukriegen. Deswegen wird diese Woche noch angehört. Also ich glaube, Ferra Zserbi, im Moment sehe ich ihn im Sommer auch nicht bei der Fußball-Europameisterschaft. Ja, also die Tendenz, würde ich jetzt auch mitgehen, nach dem, was du erzählt hast, ein Irres zustande kommen. Aber gut, dass es immerhin thematisiert wird. Ich weiß nicht, Fabian, magst du was dazu sagen? Ansonsten können wir wegen mir auch weitermachen mit dem Ding.
Es ist leider in Spanien sehr ähnlich nach wie vor. Vielleicht nicht immer auf dem Platz, wobei es immer wieder Probleme mit Vinicius gab, der auch ein Spieler ist, der viel provoziert und dementsprechend auch leichter mal Beschimpfungen provoziert von seinen Gegenspielern. Trotzdem, glaube ich, wenn die über die Stränge schlagen, dann hat man natürlich ein Problem. Und in den Kurven brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden, da ist Spanien nach wie vor auch Katastrophe. Vor allen Dingen in den Ultra-Ecken, wo halt einfach die wirklich großen Fan-Gruppen sind. Da gibt es Beschimpfungen, jetzt nicht nur rassistisch, sondern gegen die eigenen Spieler, gegen die Spieler des Gegners und natürlich auch immer wieder rassistische Beleidigungen. Das kriegst du nicht raus aus den Leuten irgendwie. Und das ist ein Thema, das sehr ähnlich ist, glaube ich, wie in Italien auch. Und ja, es ist ein trauriges Ding. Und keiner weiß so genau, wie man die ganze Sache anpacken kann. Und dementsprechend ändert sich ja auch nicht viel.
Umso wichtiger ist ja ein öffentlichkeitswirksamer und guter Umgang mit solchen Fällen dann. Jetzt steht dann eben Asarbi im Spotlight und so krude die ganze Entstehungsgeschichte ist. Tatsächlich ist es ja aber dann gut, dass sowas breit diskutiert wird, weil dann kann man anhand solcher Beispiele das Bewusstsein immer wieder schaffen. Und das funktioniert wahrscheinlich sehr viel besser als so ein Aktionsspieltag. Ja, definitiv. Wie gesagt, in Italien ist das wirklich seit Tagen das große Thema. Und wie du sagst, der Fokus ist drauf, jetzt ist halt die Frage, was kommt raus, was dann steht daraus, welche eventuellen Konsequenzen werden gezogen oder eben auch nicht. Das müssen wir uns mal abwarten. Das müssen wir abwarten und das werden wir hoffentlich auch mitbekommen. Das hat in deutschen Medien noch nicht so einen großen Widerklang gefunden, dieses Thema. Aber wenn da eine Entscheidung kommt, sollte er zum Beispiel nicht zu empfahren. Ich denke, dann wird das noch ein größeres Thema werden. Dann blicken wir nochmal in La Liga. Fabian, mit was möchtest du weitermachen? Welchen Malagerbezug möchtest du nehmen?
Ja, ich möchte gerne über Betty Sevilla sprechen. Und da gibt es mehrere Malagerbezüge sogar. Unter anderem der Trainer Manuel Pellegrini war ja damals der, der uns in dieses Champions League Viertelfinale geführt hat und der bei dieser Wundermannschaft dabei war. Aber Betty Sevilla hat im Moment ein paar harte Wochen und Monate hinter sich. Sie waren letztes Jahr europäisch dabei. Sie sind jetzt im Januar ausgeschieden, glaube ich, in der ersten Runde oder Februar der Conference League. Sie haben im Moment eine ganz schwere Phase. Sie waren am Anfang der Saison noch Platz 4, 5. Champions League war eventuell in der Aussicht. Und jetzt sind sie ziemlich weit abgerutscht. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, Platz 7, Platz 8, irgend sowas. Aber als Champions League ist sie ziemlich weit weg. Es müssten über 10 Punkte sein.
14 Punkte ist auf die Champions League aktuell.
Und ich glaube, Betty Sevilla hat einfach zwei große Probleme. Vor allem haben sie große Probleme, was die Verletzungen anbelangt. Es ist die dritte Mannschaft in Spanien mit der höchsten Verletzungsrate. 40 Verletzungen gab es allein diese Saison. 21 Spieler waren davon betroffen. Viele davon waren Leistungsträger wie Isco. FC Malaga? Istco spielt eine überragende Saison. Nachdem er mit der Union Berlin-Geschichte mehr oder weniger weg war vom Fenster, hat ihm Betty eine Chance gegeben unter Trainer Manuel Pellegrini, weil er in ihrer Auskannung vom FC Malaga. Er ist dort wieder aufgeblüht und hat eine überragende Hinterhunde gespielt und war allein dafür verantwortlich, würde ich fast behaupten. Das Betty so weit oben stand. Denn der andere zweite Zehner, den sie haben, oder Ausnahmespieler Nabil Fekir, war auch eigentlich die ganze Hinterhunde verletzt. Dann gab es noch Verletzungen von Gil Rodriguez, argentinischer Nationalspieler, auch Mark Roca, den kennen wir noch, Vellerín, der sowieso das halbe Fußballerleben verletzt ist, aber trotzdem, wenn er spielt, eigentlich wichtiger ist. Marc Bartra ist die ganze Zeit verletzt. Sie haben sogar Sokratis Papadopoulos aus dem Ruhestrand nochmal geholt, weil sie in der Innenverteidigung keinen mehr hatten. Der spielt im Moment Stamm bei Betis, mit 36 Jahren oder so. Dann kam natürlich der Afrika Cup. Dann haben sie mit Bakamu einen kumulesischen Stürmer geholt, der eigentlich richtig gut war, auch beim Afrika Cup. Der ist dann eine Woche bei Betis gewesen, hat sich verletzt. Der kommt jetzt auch erst Ende März wieder, wenn überhaupt. Also es läuft im Moment verletzungsmäßig alles andere als rund. Das ist natürlich einer der Gründe, warum sie im Moment so Probleme haben. Der andere ist natürlich wie so oft finanzieller mittelgeschuldet. Wenn man sich die Transfer-Ausgaben anschaut von Betis, sie haben dieses Jahr 70 Millionen Einnahmen bei 30 Millionen Ausgaben. Sie mussten ihre Leistungsträger verkaufen. Am Beginn der Saison, jetzt auch in der Winterpause, mussten Spielpersonal dafür holen, das natürlich ein bisschen weniger wert war, die natürlich Zeit gebraucht haben, um sich einzufinden, die sich dann auch gleich wieder verletzt haben. Also es ist eine sehr unruhige Saison für ein Team, das eigentlich weiter oben angesehen werden muss. Es kommt gerade so ein bisschen Licht nach vorne. Isco hat jetzt wieder gespielt am vergangenen Wochenende, das erste Mal nach seiner Verletzung. Fekir ist wieder dabei, William Caravaggio spielt wieder, Guido Rodriguez spielt wieder. Also ich denke, Betis kann nochmal einen guten Schlussspurt hinlegen. Aber ich sage mal so, wenn sie nicht so viele Probleme gehabt hätten, verletzungsmäßig und auch finanziell, dann wären sie schon Kandidat gewesen für die Champions League.
Ja und jetzt muss man ja froh sein, wer mit sich noch anders für den Europapokal qualifizieren kann. Also drei Niederlagen jetzt in Folge. Klar, da war einmal Atletico mit dabei, aber gegen Villarreal und gegen Rayo musst du jetzt nicht verlieren als Real Betis. Ja, interessante Entwicklung und zeigt halt auch, wie fragil das manchmal ist bei diesen Teams hinter den Top-Teams. Da kannst du es mal schaffen, eine gute Halbserie oder auch eine gute Saison zu spielen, aber dann zwei Leistungsträger weg, du kannst sie nicht adäquat ersetzen.
Da muss schon immer viel stimmen, klar. Und jetzt geht es am Wochenende, glaube ich, zu Girona, die war ja lange Zeit. Tabellen 1. waren, Tabellen 2. dann auch, die jetzt gerade so ein bisschen einen Einbruch haben. Aber trotzdem, die spielen in Girona, also es wird auch ein knöchelhartes Spiel für Betis. Auch dort kann man gut wieder verlieren, dann würden sie noch weiter abrutschen. Also im Moment eine ganz schwierige Phase für die Grün-Weißen.
Das ist also die Lage bei Real Betis, dann schauen wir nochmal in die Serie A. Christian, wir müssen über Juve sprechen. Dann läuft es auch nicht mehr so doll. Nein, allerdings, wir können einen Kreis schließen. Ich glaube, es war im Januar, als wir hier Juve ein bisschen gefeiert haben. Der Allegri Versteher Christian Bernhard war da hier. Genau, richtig. Und jetzt müssen wir es wieder aus Juvesicht leider ein bisschen korrigieren. Vielleicht erinnern sich noch ein paar, es ging darum, dass Juve dann nicht nur erfolgreich gespielt hat, sondern auch so ein gewisser frischer spielerischer Wind zu erkennen war. Jetzt, Monate später muss man sagen, es war ein Zwischenhoch. Also Juve, Wochenende 0-0 gegen Genua, teilweise wieder Pfiffe im Stadion. Aus den letzten acht Spielen hat Juve einen Sieg geholt. Und das ging eben genau los in der Phase vor dem direkten Duell mit Inter. Damals war Juve an Inter dran und war vor dem Spieltag von Inter sogar kurzfristig Tabellenführer. Zwar nur virtuell, weil Inter ein Spiel weniger hatte. Aber es war eben das Spiel vor dem Inter-Spiel, das sie dann verloren haben in San Siro. Das war ein 1-1 gegen Empoli zu Hause. Und da ist so der Knackpunkt gekommen. Das haben sie nach 10 Minuten des Millig mit Rot vom Platz geflogen, haben das Spiel dann nicht gewonnen. Und seitdem ist ergebnistechnisch sehr viel Sand in den Getriebe. Noch mal wie gesagt ein Sieger aus acht Spielen. Aber eben auch dieser spielerische Aufschwung, der so ein paar Wochen sich angedeutet hatte, ist auch wieder komplett verpufft. Ein Bild dazu ist vielleicht Vlaovic. Den haben wir ja auch im Januar zurechtgehyped. Er war auch noch bis Februar, glaube ich, der Top-5-Lieger Europas, der am öftesten getroffen hatte. Der hatte, glaube ich, in sechs Spielen acht Tore oder so. Der ist jetzt gegen Genua in der Nachspielzeit mit zweimal Gelb wegen Protestieren vom Platz geflogen. Er hat jetzt, glaube ich, dafür eine saftige Strafe, das heißt 70.000 Euro bekommen. Er kam gerade erst aus einer Sperre zurück, weil er im vorletzten Spiel auch vom Platz geflogen ist. Er ist so ein bisschen Teil des Zeichens dieser Nervosität, die da ist. Das größte Zeichen der Nervosität, aber da muss man sich nur Max Allegri anschauen, den Trainer. Der hat sich jetzt am Wochenende nach dem Spiel vor Kameras quasi einen Disput mit einem TV-Journalisten geliefert, wo du genau gemerkt hast, es ist brutale Nervosität und Angespanntheit da. Der TV-Journalist hat das Thema angesprochen, was Allegri am schwierigsten immer zu handeln hat. Wie schaut es mit der spielerischen Entwicklung aus? Und dann ging es los bei Allegri. Was sind das für Fragen? Er werde ihm hier nicht erklären, wie das Trainergeschäft funktioniert. Denn er ist der Trainer, er weiß, wie es läuft. Der Journalist soll seine journalistischen Aufgaben machen, der Trainer seine Trainer-Sachen. Also einfach nur um zu zeigen, es ist pure Nervosität da. Und das hängt auch damit zusammen, dass die Frage eben ist, was passiert im Sommer? Allegri hat noch einen Jahr Vertrag. Aber Allegri hat selbst jetzt in den letzten Wochen, als die Ergebnisse überhaupt nicht gepasst haben, ja selbst manchmal öffentlich ein bisschen thematisiert. Ah ja, jetzt geht es wieder in Frühling, dann gehen wieder die Fragen los. Wird Allegri nächstes Jahr da sein? Also er hat selbst so ein bisschen das Thema in die Öffentlichkeit gebracht. Und deswegen ist es gut, dass wir darüber reden. Es sind halt zwei Seiten, die man betrachten muss. Die spielerische Entwicklung eben, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, ja, im Januar tut sich was. Wie gesagt, das war anscheinend ein kurzes Strohfeuer. Deswegen sollte man die Frage stellen, und ich habe die auch schon letzten Sommer gestellt, wäre es vielleicht nicht besser für Juve auch, jetzt einfach mal einen Cut zu machen auf dem Trainerposten und da wirklich was Neues, Frisches zu bringen. Gehe ich weiterhin voll damit? Gar keine Frage. Auf der anderen Seite darf man halt auch nicht vergessen, Allegri war die letzten Jahre wirklich, also der Verein Juve ist nicht mehr mit dem zu vergleichen, wie noch vor ein paar Jahren, wo Juve der dominante Club in Italien war. Neun Meisterschaften in Serie A, finanziell sozusagen ganz oben. Juve hat große finanzielle Probleme, hat eine komplett neue Führung und Allegri war jetzt wirklich auch zwei, drei Jahre, er war viel mehr als nur der Trainer, er war der Blitzerpleiter. Er war eigentlich auch etwas zu dieser Manager-Rolle, wie man sie aus England kannte oder kennt, eingenommen, dass er wirklich das Ganze auch ein bisschen moderieren musste, er auch sozusagen nicht nur für die Spieler-Splitzerpleiter war, auch für den Verein. Also hat er wirklich auch dieses Jahr, er hätte Juve letztes Jahr sportlich in die Champions League geführt, er wird sie auch dieses Jahr, auch wenn sie jetzt sehr stottern, aber sie haben doch immer noch ein gutes Polster. Und Juve hat logisch, wenn wir uns den letzten Transfer-Sommer anschauen, in keinster Weise mehr die Mittel wie eben noch vor ein paar Jahren. In diesem Sommer war der einzige Neuzugang, Timothy Ware, und der spielt gar keine Rolle. Also der ist wirklich eine komplette Enttäuschung. Und Juve hat aber im Sommer Di Maria abgegeben, Bonucci abgegeben, Paredes abgegeben, Quadrado abgegeben. Man sieht daran Spieler, die erfahren sind und die auch viel Geld gekostet haben. Und da lege ich jetzt dieser Tage auch selbst gesagt, mein neuer Kurs, das was mir der Verein, die neue Clubführung von mir verlangt hat, war Junge einbauen, Gehaltsniveau absenken und das muss man sagen, ich finde, man kann den Juve-Kader wirklich nicht mit dem von Inter vergleichen. Selbst Milan und Napoli finde ich tiefer besetzt. Dementsprechend kann man schon sportlich auch, könnte man sagen, wenn du in dieser ausgeglichenen Serie A, wo wirklich viele Mannschaften Ambitionen auf die Champions League haben, wenn du das wieder eintüten solltest, dann ist das ja an sich mal was Positives, aber es schwebt halt schon wirklich immer diese große, die Frage nach der spielerischen Entwicklung weiter und drüber und die ist halt eben, wie gesagt, deswegen gut, dass ich heute da bin. Ich war derjenige, der das im Januar ein bisschen gehypt hat und ich bin jetzt der, der sagen muss, ne, es war, wenn wir uns wieder die ganze Saison anschauen, dann war es eben eine Zwischenphase, aber nicht mehr. Federico Quesa ist ein gutes Beispiel. Allegri hat ihn ja so ein bisschen, also er fühlt sich auf Außen am Abstand am wohlsten, auch in Nationalmannschaft 4-3-3, sowohl über links als über rechts kommend, der braucht Platz, um sein Tempo-Dribbling auszupacken. Und Allegri hat ihn jetzt halt im 3-5-2 als zweitens Stürmer umfunktioniert, nahe an Vlauowitsch dran, und das funktioniert nicht wirklich. Es gab schon mal eine Phase, da hat er ein paar Mal getroffen, aber er weicht jetzt auch, gerade in den letzten Wochen siehst du, er weicht immer wieder massiv auf links aus, steht dann ein bisschen Kostic auf den Füßen rum, weil da ja logisch der Schienenspieler eigentlich derjenige ist. Und Käse ist deswegen ein ganz gutes Beispiel dafür, dass die Spieler teilweise nicht da sind, wo sie sich vielleicht komplett wohlfühlen. Wahnsinnig viele Juve-Fans fordern seit Monaten, Allegri, probier es zumindest mal mit einem 4-3-3 oder einem 3-4-3. Du hast die Leute dafür, stell Wlawitsch ins Zentrum, mach Käse auf links oder rechts. Und Yildiz, da sind wir wieder beim Januar, der diese tolle Entwicklung hatte, lass die drei einfach mal zusammenspielen. Yildiz, seit dem Januar spielt eigentlich kaum mehr eine Rolle. Allegri bringt ihn kaum noch, wenn schon, bringt er ihn am 85. Und es hat wirklich so, aus der Evolution ist eine… Starknation? Oder Regression. Ja, vielleicht sogar. Also spielerisch definitiv, jetzt gegen Genua, in der ersten Halbzeit gab es zwei Abschlüsse und die waren von Gatti, vom Innenverteidiger. Also es ist problematisch, aber wie gesagt, ich finde, man muss schon das ganze Bild sehen. Also wer jetzt noch an Juve denkt, vor ein paar Jahren, das ist halt nicht mehr die Realität. Und dementsprechend ist halt die Frage, ob liegt jetzt am Ende, was behält die Oberhand? Dass Juve erstmal sagt, wow, er hat uns in die Champions League geführt, mit dem relativ jungen Kader, muss man sagen. Ich glaube, Juve hatte vor kurzem mal gegen Napoli im Topspiel, im Altersschnitt von 26 und das ist für Juve-Verhältnisse Wahnsinn. Ja, ist wirklich so. Ich glaube, sogar Allegri hat danach gesagt, das war die jüngste Juve-Mannschaft seit, ich weiß nicht, wie viel, ich glaube nicht nur Jahren, sondern Jahrzehnten. Und eben wie gesagt, diese Yildiz einbauen kam ja so, ein paar Junge ja, aber irgendwie spielerisch geht es nicht wirklich voran. Deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt, was im Sommer passiert, ob Junto Le, der Sportdirektor, der Napoli aufgebaut hat, ob man sich bei Juve traut, das mit Allegri den Cut zu machen oder ob man ihn dann doch weitermachen lässt und sagt, er bringt uns zumindest in die Champions League. Da schließt sich jetzt der Kreis. Da Juve nicht mehr die finanziellen Mittel hat, ist es logisch unfassbar wichtig, dass du diese Champions-League-Millionen hast, die dir dieses Jahr gefehlt haben. Plus kommt noch dazu, dass Juve sich jetzt auch für diese Club-WM qualifiziert hat aus Italien. Das ist in Italien schon ein Riesenthema, weil die Rede davon, dass allein die Teilnahme dir um die 50 Millionen einbringt. Das ist dann auch ein Faktor, wo du als Verein Juve sagst, ja gut, die jetzt haben, das schon wissen, ist logisch für uns ein wahnsinnig wichtiger Faktor. Ich bin gespannt, was passiert. Aber echt, kann Julian Nagelsmann Italienisch? Das würde schnell gelernt sein, würde ich mal sagen. Es ist immer was los bei Juve, aber es ist auch was los in La Liga. Wir wollen zu aller Best schauen, da freue ich mich drauf. Was ist denn da berichtenswert, Fabian?
Ja, Alaves kommt ja aus der baskischen Stadt Vitoria, der Verein. Und das ist die Heimatstadt meiner Frau. Und deswegen bin ich bei Deportivo Alaves natürlich ganz gut dabei und kenne mich dort so ein bisschen aus und bin auch immer vor Ort, wenn ich mal dort oben bin. Und es ist ein sehr kurioser Verein, denn ja, er ist eigentlich so eine typische Fahrstuhlmannschaft, eher aber so ein Zweitligaklub. Und macht aber jetzt seit ein paar Jahren einen richtig guten Job, und zwar seit Cerecheta, ein Unternehmer aus Vitoria, den Verein übernommen hat. Und Cerecheta ist bekannt dafür, weil er Baskonia, den Basketballverein, schon seit Jahren führt. Und das ist so in Spanien nach Real Madrid und Basa immer schon die drittbeste Mannschaft gewesen, immer schon in der Euro League dabei, das ist so die Champions League im Basketball. Und hat dort in einer 200.000 Einwohner-Stadt schon immer geschafft, dass sie quasi international im Fokus waren und machen dort wirklich eher vorder an der Arbeit. Und der hat sich jetzt vor ein paar Jahren auch, wie gesagt, Alaves angenommen und ist dann letztes Jahr aufgestiegen in die 1. Liga und macht dort sehr solide Arbeit mit einem Trainer, Luis Plaza, der sehr erfahren ist. Die spielen jetzt keinen wirklich schönen Fußball, sage ich mal. Sie spielen den typischen 4-2-3-1, würde ich sagen, wobei die 2-6er wirklich tief stehen und wirklich nur zwei Holding-Sixes spielen. die für das Spiel zur Störung zuständig sind. Und sie haben sehr bescheidene Mittel, denn Grechetta ist auch dafür bekannt, dass er sehr geizig ist mit seinen Ausgaben. Dementsprechend ist er auch keiner, der dort Geld einfach mal verpolert und sagt, hier, mach mal. Sondern er wirtschaftet wirklich sehr knapp bemessen. Meistens geht es ganz gut, wie bei Vasconia. Dieses Saison passt es nicht so. Bei Alavest versucht er, dieselbe Linie durchzuziehen. Und es passt. Sie haben eine ganz gute Mischung aus baskischen Spielern, aus eigenen Spielern. Sie holen sich immer wieder Talente auf Leihbasis, die sehr gut funktionieren. Dieses Jahr der Stürmer Samo Omoridion. Der gehört eigentlich Atlético Madrid und wird spätestens im Sommer dort auch wieder hingehen. Er ist mit Abstand der beste Spieler von Alavest dieses Jahr und sorgt mit seinen Toren dafür, dass sie im Moment im sicheren Mittelfeld stehen. Und eigentlich mit dem Abstieg jetzt schon nichts mehr zu tun haben. Das ist für Alavest schon mal ein Riesenerfolg. Und dann holen sie sich gerne Talente von Real Madrid. Da hat man sehr gute Beziehung. Und holt sich dort immer Jungs von der zweiten Mannschaft, die es dann nicht in die erste Mannschaft direkt schaffen, was ja bei Real Madrid eigentlich immer so ist. Die kommen dann immer erst über andere Erstliga-Teams, wenn überhaupt dann zurück zu Real Madrid. Und haben dort mit Rafa Marín einen ziemlich starken Innenverteidiger, mit Antonio Blanco einen sehr guten Sechser, die mit Sicherheit auch nicht so lange bei Alavest spielen werden, wenn sie so weitermachen. Fun-Fact vielleicht noch, es ist Juliano Simo Simeone, einer der Söhne von Giollo Simeone, ist im Moment bei Alavest. Der spielt leider sehr wenig, weil er hat sich am Anfang der Saison in der Saisonvorbereitung einen Schienbeinbruch zugezogen. In einem Testspiel wurde er übelgetreten. Und jetzt kommt er gerade erst wieder so ein bisschen hoch, aber ist ein interessanter argentinischer Wadenbeißerstürmer. Und ja, einfach interessant muss ich sagen, wie dieser kleine Clubs doch dann schafft, sich dort ganz gut zu halten. Und haben ein kleines, schmuckes Stadion. Und haben es jetzt, wie gesagt, im März kann man eigentlich schon davon ausgehen, dass sie die Liga halten werden. Auch natürlich, weil die anderen drei da unten vor allen Dingen richtig schlecht performen. Aber trotzdem, als Team mit dem zweit geringsten Budget, finde ich, ist das eine sehr ordentliche Leistung.
Aber wirklich, also nur vier Teams haben in den letzten Jahren weniger ausgegeben als Alaves. Und da sind Teams mit dabei, die auch gar nicht so viel in der ersten Liga waren. Wird denn das kutiert? Und warum ist Alaves für Realspieler dann eine gute Adresse, obwohl man einen so defensiven Fußball spielt?
Es ist halt so, du hast natürlich perfekte Voraussetzungen. Du kannst dir vorstellen, dass ja, die ganze Installationen, die Trainingsgelände, Stadion usw. das ist alles top dort, alles vom Feinsten. Und ja, es ist halt schon so, dass es eine Mannschaft ist, die sich im Endeffekt auf defensive Spielweise spezialisieren muss, um die Punkte danach einzufahren. Und wie gesagt, man hat jetzt auch vor allen Dingen Realspieler, die defensiv richtig stark sind. Und bei Real Madrid ist es schwierig, als Innenverteidiger von der zweiten Mannschaft direkt in die erste zu kommen. Da musst du dich erstmal beweisen. Und das machst du natürlich am besten bei irgendeinem Erstligisten oder einem Zweitligisten. Und dementsprechend ist das ein sehr, sehr gutes Pflaster. Und wenn du dich dort eben beweisen kannst, in einer defensiv spielbaren Mannschaft, wo du wirklich die besten der Liga gegen dich jedes Wochenende vor das Gesicht bekommst, dann ist das natürlich eine ganz gute Geschichte. Und natürlich den FC Malaga-Bezug möchte ich natürlich noch dazunehmen. Sie haben auch einen marokkanischen Innenverteidiger, Nationalspieler, der heißt Abdel Abkar.
Natürlich.
Wurde aber leider nicht mit einem Profivertrag ausgestattet, weil er viel zu schlecht behalten wurde, ist dann in die zweite Mannschaft von Al Havas und ist seit zwei, drei Jahren dort Stammspieler. Und wie gesagt, inzwischen auch Nationalspieler.
Siehst du, und ich dachte schon, der Malaga-Bezug wäre, wärst du über deine Frau. Aber es gibt sogar noch mehr. Kann man auch zählen lassen. Sehr schön. Dann lasst uns mal zu den Awards kommen. Und wir wollen dieses Mal mit dem Moment des letzten Spieltags beginnen. Und wir beginnen in Italien, Christian. Ja, das ist leider sehr trauriger. Der Generaldirektor der Fiorentina, Joe Barone, ist verstorben. Am Dienstag, glaube ich. Und das ist ja immer tragisch, ist klar. Es ist kurz vor dem Spiel, die Fiorentina, die hätte am Sonntag in Bergamo bei Atalanta gespielt. Das Spiel wurde eine Stunde davor abgesackt, weil er eben ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert wurde. Und da schon klar war, dass der Zustand sehr kritisch ist nach Herzproblemen. Und das Tragische aus Fiorentinas Sicht ist halt, die Fiorentina vor sechs Jahren erst ist ja Davide Astori, der Kapitän, damals auch verstorben. Und zwar auch im Hotel vorm Auswärtsspiel quasi. Und das war jetzt, also Barone ist nicht dann an dem Tag verstorben, aber es war sofort klar, deswegen auch die Absage, dass da was Schlimmeres passiert ist. Die Mannschaft ist auch am Abend noch sofort ins Krankenhaus, der Trainer, alle waren da, sind wirklich ein, zwei Tage da gewesen. Die Familie ist aus den USA eingeflogen, aber am Dienstag kam dann leider die Nachricht, dass er verstorben ist. Und Barone muss man sagen, die Fiorentina ist ja Rocco Commissor, ist der Präsident, Italo US-Präsident, der ja auch sehr, sag ich mal, folkloristisch manchmal unterwegs ist. Und Barone war sozusagen sein sportlicher Statthalter in Florenz. Den hat er davor auch schon bei New York Cosmos dazugeholt. Die beiden kennen sich eigentlich, die hatten früher nicht den riesen Fußballbezug. Die haben sich über finanzielle, über wirtschaftliche Dinge kennengelernt. Und Commissor hat ihn dann sofort ins Boot geholt, weil er gesagt hat, das ist genau mein Mann, dem vertraue ich. Und der hat die Fiorentina wirklich, muss man jetzt sagen, also 2019 kam er zur Fiorentina. Und was vielleicht ein paar im Blick haben, und wenn nicht mal einen Blick drauf werfen, die Fiorentina hat ein überragendes Trainingszentrum in den letzten Jahren hingelegt. Das ist der Viola-Park, ich weiß nicht, ob wir hier schon mal gesprochen haben. Das ist eines der modernsten Trainingszentrum der Welt mittlerweile. 26 Hektar groß, da gibt es zwei Stadien drin, 12 Fußballplätze, Übernachtungsmöglichkeiten glaube ich für 100 Spieler und Spielerinnen. Das ist wirklich avant-garde und das hat Barone eigentlich im Prinzip, das war so sein Hauptprojekt, das hat er vorangebracht. Und am gestrigen Mittwoch ist er auch aufgebaut worden im Viola-Park, da konnten sich die Fans verabschieden, auch alle großen Italienischen von anderen Clubs waren Vertreter da, Daniele de Rosse, der Roma-Trainer war auch da, war sehr berührend und Commisso war logisch auch da und hat auch gesagt, eines der wichtigsten Gebäude im Viola-Park wird jetzt nach Barone benannt werden. Also er hat auch sozusagen abseits des Fußball-Falls gerade strukturell wahnsinnig viel vorangebracht, weil dieser Viola-Park wirklich, ja, also in Italien definitiv neue Standards setzt und auch in Europa sich vor keinem der Top-Trainingszentren verstecken muss. Und Barone war halt immer einer, der so ein bisschen im Hintergrund agiert hat, Commisso haben die Schlagzeilen gehört, aber ein ganz wichtiger Mann und wie gesagt eben bei der Fiorentina dieser Trage. Da sind jetzt Spieler dabei, die halt vor sechs Jahren auch schon dabei waren, als Astori verstorben ist. Jetzt dein Generaldirektor, zu dem wirklich sehr viele Spielern sehr enges Verhältnis auch hatten. Der hat anscheinend ein sehr menschlich, war der sehr, sehr beliebt. Auch ganz viele Ex-Spieler haben sich jetzt in den letzten Tagen gemeldet, die jetzt nicht mehr bei der Fiorentina sind, aber mal in den Jahren bei der Fiorentina waren. Tragische Geschichte und schon wieder trifft die Fiorentina. Ganz kurz, ich weiß nicht, wie relevant es ist, aber vielleicht ist es eine Frage, die sich auch Hörern gestellt haben. Wie alt war Barone? Hoch 50, glaube ich. Und es war wohl ein Herz, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Herzstillstand war, aber es kam auch anscheinend aus dem Nichts. Also es war jetzt nicht, dass es da irgendwie, also zumindest nicht bekannte grobe Vorerkrankungen gab. Klar, es ist jetzt nicht mit Astoria vergleichbar von der Altersstruktur, aber es kam wohl, ja, aus dem Nichts. Okay, also diesmal ein dunklerer Moment, aber die sollen ja hier auch ihren Platz finden. Ich vermute aber, dass wir, wenn wir jetzt dann auf La Liga blicken, dann wieder uns um sportliche Dinge bemühen können. Fabian, was ist denn dein Moment des Spieltags gewesen?
Es gab ein Alibi-Moment, aber den möchte ich eigentlich nur ganz kurz anreißen. Es war irgendwie der Spieltag gegen den Rassismus und alle Teams sind vor dem Spieltag mit so bunten Trikots aufgelaufen, um dort zu demonstrieren, dass man gegen Rassismus ist. Ich finde solche Aktionen immer, ja, sieht nach außen ganz toll aus, bewirkt null. Aber gut, deswegen ist es für mich auch nicht der Moment des Spieltags gewesen, sondern es war eine ganz verrückte Geschichte vor dem Spiel zwischen Valencia und Villarreal. Das ist ja ein Derby sozusagen, ein richtig heißes. Und die beiden Mannschaften liegen sich auch in der Tabelle ziemlich nahe, ich glaube 8. oder 9. Also es ging ziemlich viel und Villarreal hat auch eine schwere Saison hinter sich, beziehungsweise ist ja noch gar nicht zu Ende, aber bisher standen lange ganz unten. Wir haben jetzt mit Marcelino, mit dem Trainer es geschafft, sich so ein bisschen zu fangen. Und die wurden gefilmt, als das Team vor dem Spiel zur Spielbesprechung in so einem Kinoraum halt gerufen worden ist und jeder dachte, jetzt kommt halt die Ansprache zum Spiel und die taktische Auslegung und so weiter. Und dann haben sie aber insgeheim die Kinder der Spieler gefilmt, die dann so messages an ihre Daddies rausgehauen haben, weil Vatertag vor kurzem war in Spanien. Und dann war vor dem Spiel quasi die Motivation einfach nur, dass die Kinder ihre Papis begrüßt haben, dann auch die Kinder der Trainer und des ganzen Teams und so weiter. Es wurde dann alles sehr herzlich und sehr schön vorgetragen und man hat auch gesehen, die wurden dann natürlich dabei gefilmt, wie die Tränen geflossen sind bei den Papas da und so weiter. Und es hat funktioniert, denn Real hat tatsächlich das für sich entschieden.
Aber wirklich und irgendwie schließt es an das andere dann doch an. Es ist ein Kreislauf. Dann wollen wir aber noch die sportlichen Kategorien machen. MVP und Unsung Hero. MVP würde ich sagen, starten wir mal mit. Christian, wen würdest du da gerne nominieren? Sehr gerne. Ich würde einen Maldini nominieren und zwar Daniel Maldini, den Sohn von Paulo. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich noch ein paar. Er hat schon vor drei oder vier Jahren sein Debüt, damals auch bei Milan, gegeben. Er ist jetzt mittlerweile ein bisschen auf Wanderschaft, auf Leihbasis, um Spielpraxis zu bekommen. Er ist jetzt im Januar bei Monza gelandet und macht das jetzt richtig, richtig stark. Maldini, dazu muss man so anfangen, er ist kein Innenverteidiger, sondern er ist ein Kreativer, ein Zehner. Er hat nicht das vom Papa mitgenommen, sondern er fühlt sich in der anderen Hälfte des Spielfelds wohl. Er hat am Wochenende wunderbar auf Freistoß, ich glaube mindestens 25 Meter Spiel entschieden. Das war jetzt sein 1-0-Sieg von Monza gegen Kaljeri und war in den letzten vier Spielen sein drittes Tor. Das ist eine richtig starke Verfassung. Dazu kam noch eine Vorlage, war auch beteiligt, als vor kurzem Monza Milan geschlagen hat, dieses spektakuläre 4-2 da Trantor auch vorbereitet. Man hatte das Gefühl, es hieß immer großes Talent, aber bei Milan war es noch zu früh, gar keine Frage. Dann war er an Spezia ausgeliehen, da war es nicht weiß Gott wie prickelnd. Jetzt war die erste Halbserie an Empoli ausgeliehen, da ging auch wenig. Hing auch damit zu tun, dass Empoli eine schwierige Saison hat. Er hat relativ wenig Einsatzzeiten gehabt. Jetzt im Winter zu Monza und da blüht er jetzt auf. Adriano Gagliani ist der Geschäftsführer von Monza, die große Milan-Legende, die das alles mitgemacht hat. Milan Berlusconi ist Milan. Der hat am Wochenende einen schönen Satz gesagt, endlich habe ich einen Maldini, der Tore schießt. Mit kleinem Augenzwinkern. Wie gesagt, schöne Geschichte. Es hieß immer bei Maldini, klar wissen wir, wenn du der Sohn einer solchen, ich würde sagen bei Paolo Maldini, darf man das Wort Legende verwenden. Wenn du der Sohn eines solchen Spielers bist, war ja klar, dass da von Anfang an immer ein großer Fokus drauf ist. Und dann ist immer die Frage, ist das Talent wirklich so groß wie der Name sozusagen? Oder ist halt der Name vielleicht auch größer als die sportlichen Voraussetzungen? Aber das, was er gerade spielt, zeigt, dass er definitiv sozusagen seine Berechtigung in der Serie A hat. Und ja, hoffentlich geht es für ihn so weiter. Monza ist ein sehr gutes Pflaster eben für junge Spieler, sich da auch weiter zu entwickeln. Colpani, Andrea Colpani, der macht das schon seit eineinhalb Jahren, ist auf einem guten Weg, auch so ein Kreativer. Weil Raffaele Palladino, über den wir hier auch schon mal gesprochen, ein junger Trainer, der es auch in diesem Jahr gut macht. Und ein Wort dazu eben, Maldini wurde gefragt, was ihm momentan die Verfassung gebracht hat und hat er auch explizit Palladino genannt. Und er hat gemeint, das ist gar nicht so sehr das Technische, sondern mehr so das, was er ihm so mental mitgibt. Und scheint befreiend zu wirken und schöne Geschichte. Und wie gesagt, allein der Freistoß jetzt am Wochenende, wie er den reinzwirbelt, sehr, sehr sehenswert. Wir müssen noch eine Abzweigung nehmen. Ich bin vertraglich fast schon dazu verpflegelt. Es gibt eine Power-Hörerin, Pina, die ich hiermit herzlich grüßen möchte. Die hört jede Folge des Rasenfunk schon seit ganz vielen Jahren. Sie schickt mir nach jeder Folge eine Sprachnachricht mit Feedback. Sie war auch schon mal zu Gast hier im Rasenfunk. Sie war auch in der 400. Schlusskonferenz mal zu hören. Sie hört immer die Ligatour als erstes formatisch. Sie zieht sie immer vor, wenn quasi der anderen rauskommt. Ansonsten hört sie es in der Reihenfolge. Sie hat mich schon bestimmt fünf Mal danach gefragt, kannst du mal irgendwann fragen, was eigentlich Cal di Rola und Donati bei Monster machen? Wenn wir jetzt über Monster sprechen, kannst du da kurz ein paar Worte sprechen? Also Donati spielt kaum, habe ich gesehen. Ja, genau. Also bei Cal di Rola, da war die letzte, da hat, glaube ich, Pia letzte Saison große Freude gehabt, weil das war ja diese großartige Saison von Monster, wo die, glaube ich, alle Großen auch geschlagen haben, dieses Jahr ja auch da weiter fortgesetzt. Da hat Cal di Rola sogar in San Siro das Siegtor gegen Inter geschossen. Dieses Jahr ist es auch ein bisschen ruhiger geworden. Donati, wie du ihm sagst, Donati spielt jetzt nicht die große sportliche Rolle, ist aber auch einer von den Spielern, die halt immer, wenn er gebraucht wird, ist er da. Und die passen da wirklich gut rein. Und das ist auch ein guter Punkt. Das sind so ein paar Spieler, die haben ihren Platz gefunden, die bei vielen wahrscheinlich schon von der Liste weg waren, aber die jetzt wirklich in diesem Monza-Umfeld mit Palladino eben, mit sehr vielen italienischen Spielern, das ist ja das Besondere auch bei Monza. Wir hatten darüber auch schon mal gesprochen. Bei Monza ist ganz oft, wenn man sich die Start-Life anschaut, es sind oft acht, manchmal sogar neun Italiener in der Startformation. Also ganz klarer Fokus darauf, der auch noch von Berlusconi so gewollt war sozusagen. Und wie gesagt, du hast halt mit Gagliani einen, der halt mit allen Wassern gewaschen ist, der logischerweise das Business wahrscheinlich so gut kennt wie kein anderer in der Serie A, wahrscheinlich auch international. Und mit Palladino eben Trainer, der jetzt auch dieses Jahr seine Entwicklung weitergeht. Jetzt mittlerweile sind sie wieder sogar ran an der Fiorentina, an Lazio und Napoli, sind gar nicht so weit weg. Ich glaube, es sind nur zwei, drei Punkte. Sie spielen wieder eine Saison. Letztes Jahr war die Frage, ob sie vielleicht noch weiter vorne ran können. Dann gab es dieses Jahr ein bisschen Aussetzer. Aber jetzt sind sie wieder da, haben wieder große geschlagen. Und Calirola hatte letztes Jahr noch mehr Akzente, ist aber definitiv Part of der Rotation. Sehr gut. Vielen, vielen Dank auch im Namen von Pina. Das seht ihr mal, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr müsst mir nur ein paar Jahre lang nach jeder Sendung eine Sprachnachricht schicken, dann bekommt ihr diese Vorzugsbehandlung. Aber ich denke, es wird ein paar andere auch noch interessiert haben, denn die haben ja eine Vergangenheit in der Bundesliga. Fabian, wer ist dein MVP?
Unter anderem auch letztes Jahr beim FC Malaga, auf der Trainerbank saß, den Verein aber leider nicht vom Abstieg bewahren konnte. Und jetzt hat er angeheuert bei Almeria. Sehr kurios, damit hat eigentlich auch keiner gerechnet. Und siehe da, Almeria hat am vergangenen Wochenende sein erstes Saisonspiel gewonnen. Und das auch noch auswärts bei den eigentlich starken Las Palmas, über die wir auch öfter schon gesprochen haben. Also, sehr kurios, er kam, sah und siegte, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, der erste Saisonsieg für den Saudi-Club Almeria, der mit ziemlicher Sicherheit trotz allem den Weg in die 2. Liga gehen wird.
Na, hoffentlich werden das die Saudis – sagt man das so? Naja, also hoffentlich werden das die Besitzer verkraften können. Aber wenn du jetzt eh schon so schnell am Sprechen bist, wirst du gleich deinen Anzang Hero hinterher schieben. Ich bin schon ganz gespannt.
Ich schicke gerne hinterher und schicke Grüße raus an unseren Kollegen Alex Trujka. Ich habe mich für den Trainer des FC Barcelona Xavi entschieden. Denn auf ihn wird er eigentlich regelmäßig draufgedroschen, hier von allen Medien. Und ich glaube, international kriegt er nicht nur Blumen serviert. Aber man muss ihm zugute halten, dass er tatsächlich den FC Barcelona ins Viertelfinale der Champions League geführt hat. Zugegebenermaßen gegen einen Napolé Christian, der im Moment vielleicht nicht in Topform ist, wenn man das so sagen kann. Aber trotzdem, er hat es geschafft. Und das hat Barcelona – jetzt weiß ich die Zahl – aber viele Jahre nicht mehr geschafft. Das ist natürlich für die Katalanen extrem wichtig, finanziell. Die sind natürlich nach wie vor sehr angeschlagen. Und darüber hinaus – und das hat mich fast noch am meisten gewundert – fahren die am Sonntag zur Atletico Madrid und siegen Dort Zaragoza und schreiben 3 zu 0. Und haben eine extrem runde Woche hinter sich. Obwohl Xavi auch zur Halbzeit vom Platz geflogen ist, weil er sich mal wieder mit dem Schiedsrichter angelegt hat, was er auch gerne einmal macht. Aber dadurch, dass er so viel abbekommt, habe ich mir gedacht, ich nehme diese Woche, weil er hat einfach eine Wahnsinnswoche für Barcelona abgeliefert.
Ich glaube, die Woche hat ihm auch wirklich sehr gut getan, weil er hat ja auch das Weiterkommen gegen Napoli danach für eine Generalabrechnung genutzt Richtung Journalier. Man merkt schon, wie viel Dampf da auf dem Kessel ist, auch dass er jetzt wieder gegen Atletico fliegt. Also Trainer bei Barca sein, glaube ich, auch noch als Xavi mit der Geschichte. Also was du da außenrum mitkriegst. Ich durfte dir das Hinspiel kommentieren, Napoli-Barca. Da gab es ja auch auf der PK vor dem Spiel. Da saß der niederländische zentrale Mittelfeldspieler. Der Jong, danke. Genau, der ja auch gemeint hat Richtung Journalier. Was ist denn los? Was schreibt er für Sachen? Über die angeblichen Gehälter, die er verdient und so. Man sieht bei Barca, der Druck ist immens. Xavi hat ja auch mal seinen Rücktritt zum Saisonende bekannt gegeben. Da hat er auch gesagt, du hast hier manchmal das Gefühl, es geht jeden Tag um Leben und Tod. Ich glaube, all dieser Druck ist dann halt auch abgefallen. Ich bin völlig bei Fabian. Als wir das weiterkommen, ja, total wichtig. Und dann auch noch gegen Atletico ein 3-0 nachlegen.
Jetzt wieder Tabell 2, jetzt ist eigentlich wieder alles 11-0.
8 Punkte Rückstand, klar, ich meine Real für trotzdem Meister. Aber zum ersten Mal seit 2019, 20, ist man wieder ins Viertelfinale gekommen. Damals gegen Bayern ausgestiegen. Das war dann dieses 2 zu 8, also quasi die Corona-Saison. Aber danach Achtelfinale gegen PSG raus, zweimal in der Gruppenphase raus, jeweils mit Bayern in der Gruppe. Und jetzt ins Viertelfinale gekommen gegen, okay, wieder PSG. Aber ja, finde ich sehr schön, dass Xavi hier auch mal positiv erwähnt wird. Dann fehlt uns noch der Ansatz hier aus der Serie A. Ja, und da kann ich an Fabian direkt anknüpfen, denn auch ich habe mir einen Trainer rausgesucht, eines großen Clubs, nämlich Piorli von Milan. Bei Milan geht es ja zuletzt auch viel abseits des Spielfelds. Da gab es ja vor Kurzem auch Untersuchungen oder es gibt es immer noch der Finanzbehörden über die Übernahme von Redbird. Das sind einige Fragezeichen. Die Frage, was da alles genau gelaufen ist, da steht auch im Raum – also das wird jetzt noch dauern, bis alles ausgewertet ist – aber es stand auch mal im Raum, ob es vielleicht Richtung nächste Saison zu Punktabzug kommen könnte. Also wirtschaftlich sehr schwer zu durchschauen, das Thema momentan. Dementsprechend hat Piolli dauernd den Namen Antonio Conte, der so über seinem Kopf schwebt, weil er eben auch – und da lernen wir wieder bei Redbird – Zlataniborimic seit kurzem offizieller Berater von Kardinale, von Präsidentnis. Vieles darauf hindeutet, dass vielleicht im Sommer die Zeit von Piolli zu Ende sein könnte, aber er schafft es, die Mannschaft sehr gut davon abzuschirmen. Sie haben jetzt fünf Pflichtspiel-Siege in Serie hintereinander, marschieren bis jetzt gemütlich durch die Europa League, sind mittlerweile auch Zweiter, sind dann Juve vorbeigezogen. Und wie gesagt, also die ganze Gemengelage. Piolli muss sich auch auf jeder Pressekonferenz fragen zu nicht sportlichen Themen verhalten. Und er macht es mit seiner gewohnten, ruhigen Art, sagt die Sachen, die man logisch sagen muss, so von wegen, ja, wir konzentrieren uns auf uns, wir als Mannschaft. Aber er kriegt es halt auch hin. Und Milan hat jetzt wirklich zuletzt wieder, ich glaube, sie haben auch seit Anfang, sie hatten die eine Niederlage, gab es im Hinspiel, in der Europa League im 16. Finale, im Rückspiel, wo sie aber das Hinspiel 3-0 gewonnen hatten, wo eigentlich alles klar war. Und dann gab es halt diese eine Niederlage in Monza. Ansonsten haben sie mehr oder weniger alles gewonnen. Sie spielen auch wieder offensiv, also gerade sehr torreich. Viele deutliche Siege, Leao trifft, Pulisic glaube ich in den letzten vier Spielen jeweils getroffen. Und deswegen wollte ich auch Piolli nehmen. Ein kurzer Blick zurück ins Sommer. Da gab es ja auch einen großen Cut bei Milan. Maldini wurde ja gegangen, sozusagen die ganze technische Führung. Tonali wurde verkauft für viel Geld. Und dann hat Piolli auch deutlich mehr Mitspracherecht bei den neuen Transfers gehabt. Und das kam in relativ viele neue. Loftus Chig, Reinders, Chukwese, Okafor, Pulisic. Und man muss jetzt sagen, also diese Zahl, ich bin gespannt, wie ihr sie einschätzt, aber ich, als ich sie gehört habe, fand sie ziemlich beeindruckend. Die Neuden, die jetzt im Sommer kamen, das sind ziemlich viele, ja, die haben mittlerweile in dieser Saison 40 Tore geschossen. Und das findet, also auch wettbewerbsübergreifend, also nicht nur in der Liga. Aber das finde ich schon beeindruckend. Also wie gesagt, gerade Julisic, seit Wochen eigentlich in herausfragender Form. Okafor trifft jetzt, war zwar lange verletzt. Choukouets hat jetzt auch mal getroffen. Loftus Chic funktioniert seit Wochen sehr, sehr gut. Also ja, Milan hatte viele neue. Aber trotzdem, als ich die Zahl sah, dachte ich mir, okay, wenn deine Neuden 40 Buden machen und du einer derjenigen im Sommer ja warst, der da definitiv mehr Mitspracherecht hatte, dann würde ich sagen, kann man das erst mal untergelungen abheften. Aber absolut. Spielen jetzt dann in Europa League Viertelfinale gegen die Roma. Genau. Da hat man zweimal gewonnen. Wie bitte? Da hat man zweimal gewonnen. Und, müssen wir nicht groß drum rum reden, ist ein Riesenziel von Milan in dieser Saison, der Europa League. Weil Champions League-mäßig stehen sie ja richtig gut da in der Liga. Also, glaube ich, haben ja 11 Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz 5. Also, da wird nicht mehr viel passieren. Und deswegen, der Fokus ist da an Milan ja auch mit seiner Tradition, wenn man sich als großer Europapokalferein sozusagen sehnt, ist da definitiv das Ziel in der Europa League sehr, sehr, sehr weit zu kommen. Sollte Milan weiterkommen und sollte Leverkusen weiterkommen, dann werden wir diese Partie sehen. Dann freuen wir uns darauf. Ihr zwei, es war genau wie immer, wenn man weniger Leute ist, dann hat man irgendwie auch mehr Zeit für Rückfragen und es wird genauso lang wie sonst. Aber ich danke euch sehr, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Vielen Dank an Fabian Pakolat. Danke dir, Fabian. Erhol dich noch gut, bitte. Nichts versteppen wäre wichtig. Herzlichen Dank an Christian Bernhardt. Danke dir, dass du hier warst. Aber mir auch. Und wir machen jetzt hier an dieser Stelle weiter. Hoffentlich zumindest mit Uli Hebel. Uli Hebel ist jetzt bei mir. Wir wollen sprechen über die Premier League. Uli, ich freue mich, dass du da bist.
Ich freue mich auch. Grüß dich.
Grüße dich. Wollen wir mit dem Positiven oder etwas negativeren Thema anfangen?
Ich weiß nicht, was ihr jetzt hattet, was du brauchen kannst, was dein Gebüt brauchen kannst.
Wir hatten schon alles. Das war eine wilde Achterbahnfahrt. Auch für die Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das Positivste war eigentlich, dass wir fast immer einen Bezug zum FC Malaga hatten. Da überlege ich jetzt gerade, ob es hier bei deinen beiden Teams einen gibt. Vielleicht am ehesten bei den Wolves, aber mir fällt keiner ein. Dafür fehlt der Malaga.
Da muss ich jetzt mal überlegen, ob da irgend einer im Kader stünde, der da mal war. Das wäre jetzt komplett gar nicht ausgeschlossen.
Aber lass mal über die Wolves sprechen. Warum sind die denn für dich ein Thema?
Also die laufen, glaube ich. Das wären auch so etwas wie die Anzang Heroes, wenn ich so will, generell, weil die eigentlich nie genannt werden. Und ich hatte, wenn ich ehrlich bin, vor der Saison durchaus Sorge um die. Die haben ja ganz, ganz kurz vor der Saison ihren Trainer verloren. Beziehungsweise, ja, lassen wir es mal so, verloren. Da gab es ein paar Unstrittigkeiten über den Kader und so was. Und dann ist der gegangen und mit ein paar Tagen Notiz hat dann Gary O'Neill übernommen, der vorher wiederum etwas überraschend bei Bournemouth hat gehen müssen, obwohl er einen richtig guten Job gemacht hat. Und da sind ein paar Charaktere in dem Kader, von denen ich mir nicht 100% sicher war, ob die wirklich all das tun würden, was es bräuchte, um drin zu bleiben. Die haben in der letzten Saison die erste Hinrunde fürchterlich gespielt und haben sich wirklich richtig hängen lassen. Dann kam Lopetegui und es hat eigenmaßen gut funktioniert, haben aber dann den letzten Teil der Aufstiegsgang verloren in Ruben Nevš, der sich fürs Geld entschieden hat und Saudi Arabien. Und ohne den waren die eigentlich immer eine ganze Klasse schlechter. Und dann kamen ein, zwei unbekannte Leute, was jetzt Leistungsvermögen betrifft oder sogar gänzlich unbekannt, was jetzt einfach so grundsätzlich den Namen betrifft, in Belgrad zum Beispiel. Und dann ging es aber schon los, dass die am ersten Spieltag Manchester United ein ziemlich gutes Spiel geliefert haben und ging eigentlich immer so weiter. Und ich glaube, wesentlicher Faktor dafür ist der Trainer Gary O'Neil, den ich unheimlich schätze, den ich für einen der taktisch allerstärksten in der ganzen Liga halte, weil der immer so ganz leichte Anpassungen zu jedem Gegner vornimmt. Das heißt, der geht mal ins hohe Pressing, wenn es dem Gegner überhaupt nicht liegt. Der lässt aber auch mal den Gegner kommen, bleibt erstmal passiv oder scheinbar passiv, um dann zuzugreifen. Der spielt mal mit einer Dreierkette, mal mit einer Viererkette. Je nachdem, auch wirklich recht fließend innerhalb des Spiels die Veränderungen. Also, ist ja sowieso glaube ich nicht allzu sinnvoll, immer nur zu sprechen von der Grundformation, weil die sind immer eh bloß beim Anschlusskreis. Aber danach läuft das wirklich sehr, sehr gut, hat einzelne Spieler wieder aufgeweckt, glaube ich auch. Sowas wie zum Beispiel Aït Nouri in bessere Rollen gesteckt. Hat natürlich auch, muss man auch ehrlicherweise dazu sagen, das Glück, dass ein, zwei gesund sind oder gesünder wie zum Beispiel Pedro Neto, der eigentlich dauerhaft ausfiel. Der ist jetzt halt mal wieder wenigstens zum Teil da gewesen und das merkt man, weil das echt ein richtig guter Mann ist. Hat aber auch einzelne Spieler eben gut entwickelt. Durchaus nochmal Schritte gehen lassen. Bell Guard gut eingefügt. Matthäus Kunja sieht gut aus. Ist eigentlich bis auf den Abschluss einer der progressivsten Spieler der ganzen Liga, was vor allen Dingen sogenannte Ball-Carries betrifft, also einfach den Ball quasi durch reinschleppen, Raumgewinn erzielen und so. Und macht aus einem Kader, das kann man jetzt im Nachhinein schon auch so sehen, naja gut, da steckt auch viel Talent drin. Das war aber für mich tatsächlich 50-50 mit der Tendenz zu, oh, ich weiß nicht. Und er hat aus dem Team gemacht, das jetzt in der Liga gut drauf ist, drei Siege aus vier Spielen, das zwar jetzt im FA Cup im Viertelfinale raus ist gegen den Zweitligisten, da haben sie sich deutlich mehr ausgerechnet, allerdings auch nicht mit der komplett ersten Garnitur. Ich kann dir jetzt gar nicht sagen, warum das so ist, weil ich das Spiel so nicht verfolgt habe. Und trotzdem in der Liga auf Platz 9, also mit best of the rest sozusagen, und haben in Gary O'Neill einen Trainer, glaube ich, den man jetzt in Zukunft auf dem Tableau haben sollte. Ich habe nur mal zum Beispiel, dass du weißt, wie hoch ich den einordne, habe nur mal nachgedacht, was würde denn passieren, wenn England in der Europameisterschaft in der Gruppe kleben bliebe. Oder meinetwegen sogar die nächste Runde wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht reichen, wenn es aufgeht, der dann ja wiederum angeblich auf dem Zettel von United stehen soll, was einfach Wahnsinn wäre, weil dann würde es komplett implodieren. Wäre richtig lustig. Würde ich auch gerne sehen. Aber einmal überlegt, wer könnte das sein? Wer wäre denn verfügbar? Eddie Howe hat man immer mal so kokettiert damit. Ich glaube, Gary O'Neil wäre perfekt. Ich glaube wirklich, das wäre genau der richtige Mann. Das wäre jemand, der am Anfang seiner Karriere steht, der hungrig ist, der das als totale Chance begreifen würde, der aber mit all diesen Spielern umgehen kann, weil er jetzt am zweiten Klub zeigt, dass er aus allen Möglichkeiten, egal wie geartet, alles machen kann. Und das jede Woche. Also es ist nicht nur zufällig mal für zwei, drei Wochen so gewesen, sondern Woche für Woche sind die top eingestellt. Und es gibt kein Spiel mehr mit Wolverhampton-Beteiligungen, wo ich denke, um Himmels willen. Sondern die sind immer gut, weil die den immer dem Gegner sozusagen einfach fast annullieren. Und das mag ich total gerne an denen. Und deswegen soll der auch mal genannt sein, ist wahrscheinlich dann auch wirklich das allerletzte Team, das wir noch nie besprochen haben. Und dann wird es also höchste Zeit.
Ja, finde ich sehr schön. Ich habe, nachdem Jürgen Klopp seinen Abschied verkündet hat, habe ich irgend so ein Nerd-Taktik-Blog gelesen, wurde mir irgendwie über soziale Netzwerke reingespielt. Und die haben quasi nur geguckt, wer würde vom Spielstil, von dem, was sein Team eben spielen lässt, am besten zu Liverpool passen. Und da waren eben drei Trainer. Und einer von denen war interessanterweise Sebastian Hoeneß, wo sie so fast ein Perfect-Fit sogar ausgemacht haben, einfach nur von dem, was Stuttgart spielt und was Liverpool spielt. Und dann eben als Outside-Candidate, der eben nicht so ganz von den Statistiken her passt, aber eben von allen anderen, war tatsächlich Gary O'Neill. Und da war ich auch so, dass ich mir dachte, okay, interessant.
Und jetzt zeige ich dir was. Der neue CEO der Family Sports Group, Michael Edwards, zurück. Der war schon mal Sportdirektor, ist jetzt nur einfach aufgestiegen sozusagen. Und der neue technische Direktor, Richard Hughes, die haben zusammen vor 20 Jahren bei Portsmouth schon zusammengesessen in den Videoanalyse-Räumen. Das ist also nicht komplett ausgeschlossen. Ich habe das bei uns im Podcast auch gesagt. Außen, Außenseiter-Chance, weil Liverpool sich 30 mal überlegen wird, ob das schon geht für ihn. Aber in der Making habe ich irgendwie so das Gefühl, das ist nicht ausgeschlossen. Das ist so, irgendwie hätte, würde das passen. Also vor Klopp, vor dieser jetzt – ich glaube, da kann man eher dazu sagen, das ist dann nicht so groß gegriffen – vor dieser Ära wäre der schon ein Kandidat gewesen. Weil das genau die Art Trainer war, die sie immer gesucht hatten. Und irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, das könnte eines Tages passieren.
Nicht schlecht. Und woran liegt es aber, dass die Wolves so oft verlieren? Also sie haben fast so viele Niederlagen wie Siege. Zwölf Siege, fünf Unentschieden, elf Niederlagen. Und da sind quasi die Punkte verloren gegangen, die eben dazu führen würden, dass man irgendwie in die Top-Six vielleicht irgendwo sich heranrobt. Zumindest sechs Punkte Rückstand sind es gerade auf United, auf dem sechsten Tabellenplatz. Woran liegt das?
Einfache Antwort an den Gegnern, weil die Liga einfach brutal stark ist. Und sie haben dann die Niederlagen ganz oft – wir haben über United gesprochen zu Beginn der Saison. Sie haben, glaube ich, gegen Liverpool jeweils verloren, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Sie müssten gegen United schnell nachschauen, ob das stimmt. Aber das habe ich damals auch gemacht. Ja, genau, auch 4-3 verloren haben, also zweites Mal. Gegen Arsenal waren sie gut, aber haben verloren. Dann gab es so 1-2-50-50-Spiele. Ich habe sie mal am Montag gemacht gegen Fulham, da haben sie auch verloren. 3-2, da waren sie allerdings besser. Also klare Gegnerqualität. In manchen Spielen auf Augenhöhe sind sie ein bisschen wild manchmal. Plus die Chancenverwertung. Also Kunja, kannst du in jedem Spiel ein Expected Goal hinschreiben. Ich würde tippen, dass so in etwa dann der Outcome bei 0, 25 oder so ist, weil dessen Chancenverwertung einfach zu wenig ist. Wang hatte mal eine Zeit, in der extrem effektiv war, aber schon gar nicht effizient. Wobei, da gab es auch mal sogar eine ganz kurze Phase, in der er wirklich aus einem Tor schiessen Tor gemacht hat, weil ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher bin, ob das nicht sogar letzte Saison war. Aber die brauchen schon noch ein bisschen viel. Ich würde die immer als Overachiever nennen. Die haben aus meiner Sicht mehr geholt, als sie hätten holen dürfen. Und deswegen stehen sie auf Platz 9, aber es gibt sie schon noch, diese wilden Nummern. Und gegen deutlich stärkeres Talent sind sie in der Regel dann schon noch hinten. Also Chelsea zähle ich da jetzt mal bewusst nicht mehr rein. Die haben sie zweimal weggefieselt, sind zwar richtig gut, aber die sind stärker als Chelsea, weil sie einfach viel besser trainiert sind.
Was für eine Aussage eigentlich. Aber gut, da müsste man noch mal tiefer bei Chelsea reingehen. Das machen wir vielleicht an einem anderen Tag. Heute gehen wir noch mal tiefer bei Newcastle rein. Die liegen nämlich einen Platz hinter den Wolves. Und wenn wir das abgleichen mit den Ambitionen und den Transferausgaben, die man so hatte bei Newcastle, dann erkennt man sehr schnell, aha, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich dann eher die negative Geschichte, die Uli uns mitgebracht hat. Woran hakt es denn?
Ja, glaube ich auch. Ist auch im Übrigen ganz interessant, das vielleicht dann noch abschließend an die Wolves, dann können wir den Übergang machen. Da war ja ewig die Fossun Group mit dem, man sagt ja immer, das muss man glaube ich als Journalist schreiben, dem Superagenten, Jorge Mendez, der ja da Ewigkeiten seine Spieler hingetan hat, also dass das die portugiesische Nationalmannschaft B war sozusagen. Der hat nach und nach einen Einfluss verloren und das ist auch gar nicht ungewollt beim Club. Und jetzt setzen sie etwas mehr auf die eigene Jugend. Das war so die Agenda dahinter, dass sie einfach mehr Durchbruch haben wollten aus der Academy plus logischerweise auch schon die Nachhaltigkeitsregeln. Punktabzug bei Nottingham ist jetzt auch wieder ein Thema geworden vor zwei, drei Tagen, sodass das durchaus dafür auch mitverantwortlich ist, dass sie dessen Einfluss und dessen Transfergebaren leicht beschnitten haben. Und das ist der direkte Weg zu Newcastle, weil ich glaube, ganz, ganz viel kann man unterm Strich dann mit der Folge erklären, dass Newcastle richtig Respekt hat vor den Nachhaltigkeitsregeln und deshalb nicht nachverpflichtet hat. Also, ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Vorzeitigkeit hat, ich glaube aber, irgendwie kommt eine rein. Was bei Newcastle in dieser Saison der Fall ist, ist, also vielleicht mal vom Grunde her gesprochen, es gab brutale Höhen. Es ging los am ersten Spieltag, dass ich dachte, oh, okay, die sind genauso stark, wie ich sie eingeschätzt hatte mit einem 5-1 gegen Aston Villa. Was sie jetzt im Nachhinein betrachtet, echt eine Aussage ist. Dann hatten sie Spiele wie gegen Paris Saint-Germain, als Fußball Europa auch verstanden, wie gut die sein können. Die hatten 8-0 drin gegen Sheffield und, und, und. Und dann gibt es aber auch unglaubliche Tiefen. Und da fällt mir zum Beispiel ein kurz vor der letzten Länderspielpause in 2.23, 18.30 Spiel gegen Bournemouth, wo sie mit elf, einhalb gesunden Feldspielern hingehen und einfach nicht wettbewerbsfähig sind. Und Bournemouth, die richtig zerrupft, sonst würde da Anthony Rowland gar nicht mehr im Amt sein. Das war damals das Spiel, das ihn gerettet hat. Die haben in dieser Saison, ich weiß nicht warum, das können sie auch nicht erklären, sagen sie zumindest. Es gibt einen Spieler, der eine halbwegs freie Krankenakte hat, Anthony Gordon. Der Rest war schon mal zwei Wochen oder länger verletzt und die kommen auch ganz oft auf einen Schlag, diese Verletzungen, sodass sie nicht reagieren können. Und jetzt dachte man zum Beispiel beim Torwart, bei Nick Pope, okay, jetzt holen die David Rea, weil der zum Beispiel frei ist. Aber noch nicht einmal dieses Gehalt trauen sie sich gegenzurechnen, weil die wissen, wir sind total am Ende. Und jetzt haben die, das haben wir hier auch lang und breit besprochen, Sandro Tonali verpflichtet, also den komplett einzigen sozusagen für viel Geld, von dem sie sich erhofft haben, der wird unser Passspiel auf eine neue Stufe ziehen. Der wird uns im Aufbau so helfen, weil der so anspielbar ist, weil der aus allen Situationen rauskommt. Tja, und dann handelt der sich diese Sperre ein und es ist einfach kein Null zu werden. Und das ist jetzt sozusagen die erste Stufe des Eisbergs. Die zweite ist dann, dass sie normalerweise in Teambarn total kompakt war und physisch war und immer spritzig und den Gegner allein durch diese Physis schon mal ein ganz unangenehmes Spiel gegeben haben. Das wiederum ist aber weg, weil die ja alle entweder teilverletzt oder verletzt waren. Und jetzt hat man so das Gefühl, dieses Kollektive, das Zusammenverteidigen, zusammen jede einzelne Aktion begehen, ist komplett weg. Stattdessen sind sie jetzt nicht mehr beschützt, sondern komplett frei und laufen teilweise in Konter rein. Also es ist nicht selten, dass Newcastle Spiele 3-4 ausgehen. Ich muss mal schauen, wie ich schnell finde auf die Schnelle. 3, 8 Tore in Newcastle Spielen, der Schnitt, die haben letztes Jahr am Stück 1-0 gewonnen. Oder 2-1. Im allerschlimmsten Fall. Aber das war schon furchtbar, wenn sie ein Gegentor kassiert haben, weil es einfach de facto nie passiert ist. Und das ist das große Problem. 0, 0 Kontrolle, 0, 0 Stärke, keine Fitness, kein gar nichts. Und darüber hinaus, und das ist ja das große Problem, das jetzt natürlich auch schon mal nach dem Trainer gefragt wird, Eddie Howe, wie es da aussieht. Ich habe mit einem Kollegen, der ganz gut vernetzt ist, in Newcastle telefoniert, der mir gesagt hat, also zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt gehen alle davon aus, dass Eddie Howe okay sein wird, weil er in der ersten Saison genug angeboten haben sollte. Das Problem ist nur, der Verein ist in Riyadh geführt, aus Riyadh geführt. Und niemand weiß, wie die reagieren da. Also wenn sie denken, okay, der europäische Wettbewerb ist in Gefahr, was machen sie dann? Denken sie, dass sie nicht vor der Entwicklung waren mit der Qualifikation für die Champions League, sondern dass das vielleicht normal war? Was machen sie dann? Die Stellvertreterin hier in England, Amanda Stavely, das ist ja so das Gesicht von Newcastle, die wiederum hat jetzt schon einige Male auch gesagt, nee, Eddie Howe, das passt alles, der ist bei uns total sicher, wir wollen ihn nicht ablösen, nichts. Und der Kollege, von dem ich gesprochen habe, hat mir auch gesagt, die meisten Entscheidungen werden im Moment schon noch in England getroffen, aber wenn die Saudis ihr in West angegriffen sehen, was würde dann passieren? Das heißt, man kann es nicht sagen. Dazu gibt es den Sportdirektor, der das Ganze alles entworfen hat mit klugen Transfers, der sich zu Manchester United verändern möchte. Das heißt, der Club ist irgendwie an so einer Art Scheideweg im Moment. Das heißt, also erstens Verletzungen, weiß man nicht, was das mit einzelnen Spielern macht. Kieran Chippe, der zum Beispiel auch schon mal raus wollte aus der ganzen Geschichte, was sich damals für einen völligen Schwachsinn hielt, weil ich es mir einfach nicht vorstellen konnte. Dann die totale Angst vor den Nachhaltigkeitsregeln und möglicherweise wissen sie auch schon, dass da was droht. Und der Abgang eines Typen, dem man zutrauen würde, als er mit dem ganzen Wahnsinn klar käme. Also eine interessante Phase des Vereins. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, bezwingend negativ, aber interessant.
Ja, definitiv. Und vor allem das Eingreifen der Nachhaltigkeitsregeln. Das ist so interessant, weil man selber hat das so ökologisch noch verknüpft. Aber hier ist es natürlich nur ökonomisch gemeint. Das ist wirklich ein Thema. Also wir haben es in La Liga schon ganz prominent gesehen, Barca und so weiter und andere Clubs, die ihre Spiele nicht registrieren dürfen. Aber halt auch in der Premier League. Und gleichzeitig gibt es ja quasi zwei allerlei Nachhaltigkeitsregeln. Es gibt quasi die der Liga und die der UEFA. Die der Liga sind ein bisschen härter als die der UEFA. Das heißt, wenn du quasi bei denen allein bist, also das hinbekommst, dann schaffst du es auch bei der UEFA. Total interessantes Thema. Gleichzeitig, wenn man auch hört, dass die Bayern immer sagen, wir setzen uns dafür ein, dass es eben solche Regeln UEFA weit gibt und so weiter. Und man gleichzeitig aber erkennt, manche Ligen sind da eigentlich sogar weiter als zum Beispiel die Bundesliga, wo es sowas nicht gibt. Finde ich sehr interessant und hat ja auch auf den Transfermarkt eingegriffen. Ich habe gehört aus dem – jetzt bin ich mal hier Plattigold – aus dem Beraterumfeld, aber es gab durchaus Bundesligisten, die darauf gehofft haben, dass ihnen noch jemand teuer abgekauft wird, der in der Hinterrunde gut performt hat. Aber der Markt war nicht da, weil eben ganz viele Premier League-Vereine genau aus diesem Grund gesagt haben, lieber nicht nochmal nachrüsten. Da müssen wir jetzt mal gucken, ob wir es nicht so hinkriegen.
Ja, ist so. Wenn du dir die Bilanzen des Wintertransferfensters anschaust in England, das war lächerlich. Es war nicht nur für englische Verhältnisse lächerlich, sondern da ist nichts passiert. Ich habe mir zu jedem Team die Stichpunkte gemacht, was ich denke, dass sie tun werden, bevor es losging. Und ich habe bei 20 Clubs, glaube ich, 17-mal durchgestrichen, weil sie nichts getan haben. Und das ist schon erstaunlich. Diese Nachhaltigkeitsregeln sind ja auch eine Wissenschaft für sich. Das hat Richard Masters, der CEO der Premier League, auch noch mal klargemacht. Wir werden nichts erfahren über die Strafen und warum sie verhängt wurden. Es gibt diesen einen Betrag, der drüber steht, so und so viele Minus darf man machen. Wenn du darüber hinaus bist, dann kriegst du eine Strafe. Das ist, was wir wissen im Moment. Wie es berechnet wird, wissen wir nicht. Und das ist zum Beispiel jetzt ganz erstaunlich bei dem Fall Nottingham. Nottingham denkt von sich selbst, sie haben 10 Millionen Pfund weniger Minus erwirtschaftet, als die Premier League ihnen ausweist. Aber, und das ist ja das ganz erstaunliche, also die Fälle sind auf der einen Seite total vergleichbar mit Everton, die ja zunächst mal 10 Punkte Abzug bekommen haben. Das ist dann später reduziert worden auf 6. Und jetzt kriegt Nottingham 4 Punkte Abzug. Die hätten ursprünglich 6 bekommen sollen. Aber, weil sie selbst proaktiv die Unterlagen eingeschickt haben, haben sie das ihnen zugute gehalten und zwei weniger gegeben sozusagen. Und bei Everton war ursprünglich plus zwei, weil angeblich die, so muss ich vorsichtig sein, ob das juristisch korrekt ist, aber weil angeblich die Unterlagen zumindest nicht komplett ausgehändigt wurden. Also war teilweise sogar von Fälschungen die Rede. Deswegen haben sie noch mal plus zwei obendrauf bekommen, in Sachen Minus, wenn es nur allgemein vernünftig ist. Jetzt hat aber grundsätzlich Nottingham einen höheren Betrag an Verstößen ausgewiesen bekommen als Everton, haben aber weniger Punkteabzug. Und jetzt sitzen natürlich die Fans zu Hause und sagen, hä? Und die Premier League sagt, ja, wir können nicht weiter ins Detail gehen, weil das ist zu intim, was dann da rauskäme von den Geschäftsbilanzen der Premier League. Und jetzt sage ich, okay, und was soll ich jetzt machen? Ich kann mich da gar nicht dazu seriös äußern. Ich kann einfach nur sagen, vielleicht geht der Journalismus eh in Richtung Gefühlsjournalismus, dann ist es wieder ganz cool, dann kann man sagen, gefühlt ist das okay oder nicht, aber ich kann dir noch nicht mal eine richtige Außerwelt übertreffen.
Also Uli, grundsätzlich geht es um Sportjournalismus, wer sich für seine Tweets nicht bezahlen lässt, der hat den Schuss nicht gehört. Und dann ist es aber genau dieses Problem, der intransparent und man müsste halt dem Verband vertrauen, oder dem Liga-Verband natürlich, wenn man denen halt so vertrauen könnte. Aber damit sind wir ja quasi schon bei deinem Moment des Spieltanks. Also Nottingham, minus diese vier Punkte, dann wäre man jetzt eben auf einem Abstiegsplatz. Mit den vier Punkten, dann wäre man punktgleich mit Everton, die ja eben die Punkte abgezogen bekommen haben. Ich habe diese Irritation, die du jetzt geschildert hast, die habe ich auch so gelesen bei Fans, die eben mitbekommen haben, Nottingham bekommt Punkte abgezogen, weil dann nämlich gleich der Everton-Vergleichsfall aufgemacht wurde und gesagt wurde, ja, mal gucken, wie viele Punkte das dann wirklich sind und weil aber auch gleich der Everton-Vergleichsfall aufgemacht wurde nach dem Motto, Moment mal, das ergibt ja alles gar keinen Sinn. Du kannst es jetzt ja auch nicht wissen, gleichzeitig habe ich das Gefühl, in dieser Saison werden wahrscheinlich die Standards definiert bei der Premier League, wie man mit solchen Punktabzügen umgeht. Denkst du, da wird sich jetzt in der Berufung doch mal was tun, weil natürlich hat Nottingham Berufung eingelegt.
Ja, denke ich schon. Das hat man zwischen den Zeilen schon so gelesen. Die Premier League hatte ganz fest vor, ganz gleich, was in den Unterlagen Nottinghams stehen würde, einen Punktabzug zu verhängen. Und ehrlicherweise, das muss man ja wiederum zugute halten, der Sheriff Masters, der jetzt durch die Premier League läuft, der hat ja insofern recht, als dass der Rest der Liga weiß, hoppla, lieber nicht. Insofern haben sie recht mit dem, was sie tun. Aber weil eben klar war, sie wollen Abzug verhängen, habe ich das Gefühl, dass sie schon mal eine Karenz eingearbeitet haben von nochmal vielleicht zwei Punkten, vielleicht einer, das weiß ich nicht, aber um… Also diese 10 Punkte Abzug, die sind ja beispiellos in der Geschichte des europäischen Top-Fußballs. Sie haben 10 Punkte in einer Saison. Unglaublich, dass Everton überhaupt noch im Mix war. Wahnsinn. Deswegen wirken die sechs jetzt nicht so hart, die sie jetzt haben, und die vier von Nottingham eigentlich fast schon weich im Vergleich. Das ist schon ein ganz schönes Stück für den Abstiegskandidaten in dieser Liga. Nicht einfach. Ja, ich glaube, da wird sich… Also erstens sage ich, die kriegen Recht. Da gibt es noch eine kleine Reduktion zumindest. Dann ist trotzdem der Punkt der Liga gemacht. Und trotzdem, auf der anderen Seite kommt Nottingham einigermaßen raus. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es noch ein paar Schwächen. Wir haben die Spielklig und Rush lang und breit diskutiert. Es gibt, finde ich noch, also gerade in diesem Nottingham-Fall. Nottingham denkt zum Beispiel, dass ein Transfer hätte reinfließen müssen. Und das ist aus ihrer Sicht, also auch das ist nur Mutmaßung, niemand weiß es. Aber das ist die Mutmaßung. Und so äußert sich zum Teil auch Nottinghams Presseabteilung, dass sie da denken, dass sie zehn Millionen mehr hätten einnehmen müssen. Und denen hat man ihnen aber nicht mehr zugerechnet, weil man gesagt hat, naja, da ist ja der Stichtag. Und dann sagt Nottingham, und das ist im Übrigen Teil der Urteilsbegründung, sie haben ihnen zugute gelegt, dass sie ja versucht haben, Brandon Johnson, also muss Brandon Johnson sein, aber Spieler A ist immer genannt worden, Spieler A wollten sie ja noch verkaufen innerhalb des Junis für dann am Ende, ich glaube, 47 Millionen Pfund und dann wären sie ja komplett in Ordnung gewesen. Und sie haben aber aufgrund eines Beraterwechselns blablabla Spieler A nicht transferieren können. Und jetzt sage ich, ja gut, Moment, also dann sage ich, wenn das Nottingham gewusst hätte, dann hätten sie ja sagen können, Moment, das ist unser wichtigster Spieler der letzten Saison gewesen, dann schleppe ich den gleich bis Ende Mai durch, weil das ist ja urscht. Also dann können wir uns ja selber unsere Zeitfenster bauen. Ab wann muss ich dann anmelden? Wir würden ihn übrigens gerne verkaufen, aber wir finden keinen, weil der muss jetzt die Berateragentur wechseln. Da wird es ein bisschen schwammig und da, glaube ich, gibt es auch noch eine Möglichkeit, also ich habe 0, 0 Ahnung von Jura, aber für meine Verständnis, für meinen Begriff, würde ich denken, da hat Nottingham eine echte Chance. Und da hat aber dann auch Everton eine echte Chance, weil die werden dann auch sagen, also Jungs, wir wollten auch unanah verkaufen, weil wollte halt keiner. Und wie bewerten wir dann die Werte der Spieler? Also wir sind jetzt wieder, wie du vorher gesagt hast, beim Markt. Jetzt kann ja Everton sagen, wir hätten den ja auch gerne im Jahr neu verkauft, aber wegen eurer Regeln kommt ja keiner mehr. Also da sind noch ein paar interessante Themen, die glaube ich nicht so richtig – vielleicht sind sie auch bedacht worden – das Problem ist ja, dass wir nichts erfahren. Also weder wir, noch die Fans, was ja noch viel schlimmer ist, du hattest ja bei Everton jahrelang nur das Gefühl eines Chaos, wir wussten es ja nicht. Es war nur so, okay da haben sie wieder gewechselt, da und da und da und der will dies und der will das und dann gab es ja fast so bürgerkriegsartige Zustände, mal im Dezember des letzten Jahres. Man war schon 22 sogar, wechselt von 22 auf 23 und dann hat man irgendwie gedacht, naja da wird schon irgendwas nicht stimmen und man kann ja ungefähr dann so die Bilanzen insofern, was wir wissen, lesen und sagen, okay Mujiri hat das, das und das und das ausgegeben, hat noch vier Trainer unter Vertrag, okay, wahrscheinlich werden sie nicht wahnsinnig viel Geld einnehmen, aber wir wussten es nicht. Bis jetzt das kam und wir jetzt auch nur die eine Zahl kennen, ein Gesamtminus, das sie gemacht haben und halt wissen, okay, das ist wirklich Chaos, aber mehr wissen wir eigentlich und das finde ich sehr unbefriedigend, muss ich sagen.
Ja, verstehe ich total und gleichzeitig, wer weiß, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Zurückhaltung da Details zu nennen auch daherkommt. Sollte Nottingham jetzt absteigen, dann steht es ihnen ja frei, also außer es ist komplett anders geregelt, aber auch noch vor einem Zivilgericht dagegen zu klagen, dass sie deswegen abgestiegen sind und vermutlich ist man auch bei der Liga deswegen vielleicht in manchen Punkten dann intransparenter, weil man da gar keine Einfallschneisen aufmachen möchte.
Und unter dem Strich aber wahrscheinlich auch etwas nachgiebiger.
Ja, ja, das definitiv, ja.
Wenn du nur zwei Punkte abziehst, dann kann man sagen, naja gut, die hätte da auch unterwegs irgendwo holen können.
Ja, und ob jetzt looten, wenn die dann runtergehen, die haben ja nicht die Lobby, dass die dann sagen können, hey Mensch, wir sind… Ach, es ist ganz fantastisch. Also Nottingham bekommt Punkte abgezogen, wir schauen mal, wie viele. Jetzt fehlt uns dann, das war unser Moment, uns fehlt noch MVP und Anzang Hero. Wer ist denn dein MVP?
Also, als MVP habe ich dir auch schon im Vorgespräch gesagt, hätte man einen nennen können, den man auch als Anzang Hero nennen könnte. Aber wer Fantasy Football spielt, der weiß, dass der nicht unbesungen ist, deswegen nehme ich ihn als MVP. Rodrigo Moniz hat seit Anfang Februar sieben Tore in der Premier League erzielt und das in den letzten sieben Spielen. Der war vorher ein absoluter Verkaufskandidat, zum Teil Stürmer Nummer 3 bei Fulham und ist jetzt mehr oder weniger mangels alternativen auf einmal reingekommen und sieht gut aus. Also, das ist das Witzige. Ich habe Ende Januar mit meinem Bruder gesprochen, der hatte dieses erste Spiel, das er getroffen hat mit Fulham und hat gesagt, und was hast du so zudem, weil ich die zwei, drei, vier Mal in Folge gemacht habe. Also hat von allem ein bisschen, aber ist nicht überzeugend. Und dann hat er mich nach dem Spiel angerufen und gesagt, ja, der hat von allem ein bisschen, das ist ja Wahnsinn, was der alles hat. Also, der ist clever in den Bewegungen, der ist ab dem guten Tor, der ist nicht superschnell, aber hat eine gewisse Dynamik, kann den Ball festmachen, ohne dass man jetzt sagen würde, der geht auch nur in die Nähe des Zielspielers, der hat ein ordentliches Kopfballspiel, aber kein Horst Robesch. Also, der ist ziemlich komplett und vielleicht hat er auch noch ein wenig Potenzial, in jedem Fall funktioniert es bei dem optimal im Moment und so sieht er so fast so Luis Suarez Zero aus, so würde ich es ungefähr ausdrücken wollen. Noch nicht ganz so, also dann noch nicht so geduscht, mit Zucker logischerweise, aber ansonsten geht er so in die Richtung.
Ja, sehr, sehr gut, sehr schöne Wahl Rodrigo Moniz.
Da habe ich jetzt echt lange überlegt, aber wahrscheinlich weil der wirklich wenigen Begriff war und nominiert worden ist zum ersten Mal für die englische Nationalmannschaft, ist das durchaus eine gute Wahl. Cherith Brentwayt habe ich mal genommen, den Verteidiger bei Everton, der von einer durchaus erfolgreichen Lei bei PSW zurückkam, da kann man den schon auf dem Schirm gehabt haben, so ist es jetzt nicht, aber für die allermeisten Engländer kein richtiger Begriff gewesen und ist so, also das ist die Regenkarnation von Primaverde Sacker, muss man so nichts vormachen, und der ist ein guter, harter, großer, starker Innenverteidiger, den jetzt Southgate mitgenommen hat, mal sicherlich auch, weil Gehi nicht available ist gerade im Moment, ansonsten hätte der möglicherweise den Vorzug gehabt, aber da gab es schon ein paar Augenbrauen, die hochgegangen sind, als der nominiert worden ist. Ich finde aber durchaus, dass das einer ist, der eine sehr, sehr konstante Saison spielt und bei Everton auch dafür sorgt, dass sie nicht weiter die Nachhaltigkeitsregeln haben strapazieren müssen, weil der halt schon sehr, sehr gut funktioniert hat und ja de facto, also eigene Jugend ist ein bisschen übertrieben, aber er ist schon eine Zeit lang da.
Sehr, sehr schön. Jared Brandt-Wade, wir hoffen alle, dass er irgendwann mal mit Martin Brandt-Wade zusammen spielt und dass du es dann kommentiert darfst.
Und dann brauchen wir Transferjournalisten, die du, wie ich gelernt habe, sehr schätzt.
Ja, total. Das ist die Zukunft, Uli. Ich sehe mich selbst da. Ich wäre der Maxi-Goal, werde ich in Zukunft sein. Dann brauche ich den Rasenfunk nicht mehr. Uli, ich danke dir sehr herzlich. Es hat große Freude mit dir gemacht, mal wieder hier über die Premier League zu sprechen. Danke, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast. Und danke natürlich auch nochmal an Fabian Pakulat und an Christian Bernhardt und natürlich auch an euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir werden hier auch nicht für einzelne Sendungen bezahlt. Das alles, was will kommen, kommt von euch. Und in dieser Sendung danke ich Tim Ranbach, Tommy, Dominik aus Karlsruhe, Sebastian, Sostinitore, TartanArmy und Ben. Viva Soccer Gourmands, schreibt er noch dazu. Sie alle unterstützen uns auf rasenfunk.de slash supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und an alle, die das schon getan haben, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. Und an alle, die das noch tun werden, voraus auch schon mal herzlichen Dank. Ihr könnt auf rasenfunk.de noch jede Menge andere Sendungen finden von uns, die wir so machen. Ihr könnt uns auf allen Plattformen folgen. Und ihr könnt uns sehr gerne auch weiterempfehlen. Danke, dass ihr hier immer zuhört. Danke für euer Feedback auch im Forum unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Unter diesem Video oder wo auch immer ihr das hier genießt. Habt eine gute Zeit. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bleibt uns gewogen und hört unbedingt auch mal in die anderen Sendungen rein. Es ist wieder sehr viel veröffentlicht worden. Zum VfB Stuttgart zum Beispiel, zur Männer-Bundesliga, zur Frauen-Bundesliga. Alles hier im Rasenfunk. Bis bald.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.